dope sauce
hey hey hey are we live people let us
know that we're live tell us we need you
to say it in the comments we're doing we
got the DC Studios announcement finally
oh yeah we wanted to go live before
Grace Randolph and John campio went live
that was just the main objective sure I
could go here for a stream I'm so
excited all right just we just need
confirmation from you guys that you can
hear us all right perfect Bell says we
are live okay I trust him alrighty well
thank you guys so much for being here uh
we're gonna try to design this a little
bit differently for the beginning parts
of our live stream we want to see what
James Gunn had to say I I personally did
read
um some of the Slate already I read the
whole sleep
I know nothing Corey has not read uh
knows nothing but James Gunn did put out
a video so what we're gonna do right now
is we're gonna react to this video that
James Gunn put out uh I even though I
read through the list I haven't heard
what he's had to say yet John hasn't
heard it and koi hasn't heard it so have
you read it do you know I've seen like
disjointed Snippets okay so you're in
the middle of you guys okay basically
not much Mama Bear Papa Bear Just Right
what is he doing all this Tech stuff
let's do this all right James Gunn here
we go let's see hey everybody
hey everybody I'm James gunns I'm the
co-ceo of DC Studios so as many of you
know DC has been disconnected in film
and television
Randolph is about to go live and then
she's gonna break this all down before
us then John Camp hey everybody I'm at
the screen but she's gonna go this
doesn't work this doesn't work this
doesn't work what are we gonna do we are
here we have to watch this James Gunn
video first and then we're gonna talk
about everything and I know nothing and
it's been like Christmas Eve but it's
long it's been very long oh John you
have to make it drastically let everyone
in this chat down no I think John's
doing his best the fever I am not the
fever for the flavor
patience for this right now all right
I'm excited for people to watch this
back later and be like what's happening
here why is that redhead very
uncomfortable not knowing what's
happened the rest of the world knows
these movies we're going to go through
this slate in a second we just want to
hear what James Gunn has to say hey
everybody I'm James Gunn okay I'm the
co-ceo of DC Studios so as many any of
you know DC has been disconnected in
film and television for a long time and
it's one of you know our jobs mine and
Peters is to come in and make sure the
DCU is connected in film television
gaming and animation that the characters
are consistent played by the same actors
and it works within one story and if
something is outside of that like Matt
Reeves Batman or Chris Phillips Joker or
Teen Titans Go that it is clearly
labeled as DC elseworld outside
Peter and I have gotten pretty lucky in
terms of the four projects that are
coming out over the next year first we
have Shazam Fury of the Gods Shazam has
always been off kind of in his own part
of the DCU talk about the Pfizer things
Jack Zach Levi
directly into the flash a fantastic
movie that I really love that resets the
entire DC Universe then to move into
Bluetooth
who's a marvelous part of the DCU
um
Aquaman 2 which leads directly into our
next few projects which I'm going to
tell you about oh [__] Superman and I
along with a group of very talented
writers have started to map out an eight
to ten year plan of what DC Studios will
be in film television and gaming this
first chapter is called Gods and
Monsters now this is what I'm about to
tell you is a part of the first chapter
it's not the entire first chapter the
first project is Creature Commandos
nice in all the episodes is something
we're going to do that's a little bit
different in DC is we're going to have
characters move into animation out of
Animation they're usually having the
same actor play their voice as who plays
them in live action oh that's great
this is the story of Amanda Waller who
played by Viola Davis
is going to team up with members of Team
Peacemaker and this is a story that's
been created by Crystal Henry who did
Watchmen and Jeremy Carver who created
the Doom Patrol it is a fantastic story
that's out of this world and I can't
wait for people creators next up is the
big one the true beginning of the DCU
this is called
written by me I'm in the middle of it
I'm having a great time doing it and
Superman will be released into theaters
okay the next
Premiere HBO television series called
lanterns this is a story
and Hal Jordan and we have a few others
TV show which is almost like True
Detective with a couple of Green
Lanterns who are space cops watching
over Precinct Earth in it they
discovered a terrifying mystery that
ties into our largest story of the DC
whoa
The Authority The Authority there we go
there we go it's based on The Marvelous
Wild Storm characters we are now
bringing into the DCU and will interact
with all of our primary DCU characters
The Authority are a group of superheroes
think the world is broken and they want
to fix it by any means necessary I think
it's a very different look at
superheroes those television series
called Paradise Lost Paradise Lost is a
story of Paradise Island usually known
as the mascara which is the birthplace
of Wonder Woman it's almost like Game of
Thrones with Westeros you read this
comic with all of these I love Paradise
Lost Paradise Island the introduction of
the dcu's Batman is the Brave and the
ball
story of Batman and his actual genius
Damien Wayans holy [__] Damian Wayne
that way
our bat family yeah
he's a loser from the future who uses
future technology to come back to
present day and become a super nice
story of imposter syndrome on an HBO Max
series one of my favorite comic book
series from last year was Tom King's run
on Supergirl woman of tomorrow so we're
going to turn that into a big science
fiction Epic film now Superman was the
guy who was sent to Earth in raised by
loving parents we're a Supergirl in this
story she is a character who was raised
on a chunk of Krypton she watched
everybody around her perish in some
terrible way
it's one of my favorites of all time the
last thing we're going to talk about a
very dark Horror Story in the origins of
the monster who is oh my God
I knew that this was a once in a
lifetime opportunity to do something
very different one of the things that's
very important for me in all of these
movies and TV series is that the
director's vision and the vision of the
writers and all of the creators is
unique and something special
storytelling is always king that's all
that matters to us and I want to be true
to those the Crossovers Easter eggs
really give you something different than
you've ever seen before anyway thank you
everybody I appreciate you watching this
Choice exciting for you because it's
really exciting for me and I can't wait
to start to dive into these stories with
you guys on this Grand Adventure thank
you so much Tom King has been tweeting
working on Hollywood stuff can't talk
about it he's probably writing that
Supergirl movie like dude that is the
one of the best Supergirl runs Tom King
is one of the best people to be involved
in your like your sanctum and like the
choices of all these picks these are all
very different than anything Marvel
would do these are all leaning a lot
more adult which I think is way better
for these characters yeah it is a broad
array of Supernatural to Cosmic to
ground level it's teams that don't need
setup movies like The Authority you can
just dive in and it is expansive in a
way that allows your Universe to feel
rich and whole without having to be
interconnected looking for Easter eggs
like every one of those picks is the
strength of DC in that Wild Storm and
vertigo and and your Justice League they
all feel different but it's Universal in
one that is such a [__] slate
oh my God yeah like that was better than
I hoped yeah that was awesome I I heard
I read the titles I read the titles
but my expectations were 12. and that
was a 15. sorry I only read the title so
I was like I have familiarity with this
and when I heard Brave in the Bold I I
was thinking to myself is this John do
we can you do me a favor John uh can you
pull it can you pull up some can you
like grab screenshots of what James Gunn
was talking about so we could sort of
like hover through yeah I had
screenshots pulled when I read the
titles but I didn't realize James Gunn
was going to provide yeah
a little more time yeah so um yeah hey
everybody I'm James Gunn okay I'm the
co-ceo of DC students before so as many
of you know these bold uh like and and
so I was like maybe it won't be Batman
maybe it'll be like some weird James gun
choice of a bunch of like 40s like I
don't know there's half of others
Vigilantes coming together sometimes
Brave in the bowl that just associated
with like Justice League from time to
time and so then when I heard okay it is
a Batman story I'm like oh sweet but I
wasn't expecting bat family so it's at
all like that's the smartest thing you
can do is because that's what the fans
have been lobbying for but it also
separates him from every like we've had
nine Batman like this is the best way to
be a different Batman yeah like you make
it the bad family you can have Nightwing
and bloodhaven you can have Damien
Wayne's story you can also already have
like Tim Drake established as killed by
Joker which gives you an established
like run on Joker's Batman relationship
without doing about Reeves just did
because he just said that separate it's
that's the best yeah it's amazing John
which project are you personally most
excited for I'm going to challenge you
to pull up a photo while you're also
talking about I am always I'll try to
grab some photos myself right now trying
to help you out here I am always that's
brilliant I am always a sucker for a
Swamp Thing and to see a swamp thing you
know they've tried to bring it to life
multiple times they had to show that
that was sort of beloved by some but
crashed because it didn't get enough
viewership I've always been looking
forward to this side of the universe and
yeah this uh again Jokes Aside about
Alan Moore I think there's a lot you can
do with this character and it is one of
those things where I don't know I like
the Monstrous side of these superhero
universes I always have like you know
Solomon grundier characters like that on
my mind and so seeing that we would do a
Swamp Thing and uh how that could
further expand the universe and
especially the idea of Swamp Thing being
a part of the universe and not just like
you know a sequestered elseworld's
entity hopefully would be sort of a neat
thing to me or just I don't know uh full
dis disclosure I don't know much I'm not
an expert on Booster Gold but that just
sounds like sofa dude he is a blast like
the little I know about that character
that sounds like it I mean Chris Pratt
might get to stay working with James
Gunn because he's Chris Pratt really
quick I appreciate everyone who's here
right now if you guys can leave a like
that would be very much appreciated we
are going to be taking we are going to
be going through the chat we just want
to discuss
um our thoughts first since this is our
first time learning all this so we just
want to kind of discuss some quick stuff
that we're going to focus on you guys in
the chat and you guys will continue to
dictate the rest of how this live stream
will go
um you know what I really liked about
the the Creature Commandos um unveiling
was when he's because you know like
they're they were like a World War II
characters and and consists of like
Monsters and [__] like yeah they're like
that like a Frankenstein's monster
vampires and stuff and what was really
cool was that he made clear up front for
the for the sake of continuity because I
do like like Star Wars has done it uh
several times now where you do well I
don't know about several times what they
do a Boca Town but I like when they do
keep it
okay let me rephrase this what's
interesting to me is how they're going
to start it off animated and then we're
gonna see that same voice actors become
live action yes and to establish that up
front I don't know of that ever
happening usually it's kind of just an
exciting Venture when they decide to do
that or when it's in Reverse when they
decide to take the live action and make
them animated I think it's really cool
that they're like our first thing it's
gonna be Creature Commandos I know it's
out of this world but then we're also
they're also going to be in live action
I think that's a really cool uh way to
go about it I also think as far as
launching a slate it's genius because
you could have had that animation be
done in secret for how like this could
be so deep in development and then you
add the voice actors like this could be
almost ready to go soon because they do
have a Year's worth of movies on the
docket like that those are already
cooking yeah yeah also what a bold by
the way Flash resets the universe and
then we've got to start like just
casually Flashpoint is a genius way
we've said from the jump and and I've
the 38 videos where I've talked talked
about what I would do is Flashpoint
resetting they just confirmed that but
they that's how they can also keep like
Amanda Waller that's how they can also
keep some actors and so it's really
interesting that we're gonna have Blue
Beetle kind of be our Gateway between
universes in our this year so
technically the DCU starts this year
while James Gunn's also able to make it
so Superman is the Iron Man of the
greater DC Universe which is interesting
yeah I thought it was really interesting
that they said that because I think
everyone's speculation with Jason Momo
was that Aquaman's done he's going to be
Lobo where everyone's mind was going
um but there seemed to be no indication
at all that Aquaman is done for it he
just seems like exactly they're like
Aquaman 2 is actually going to be the
Kickstart for our universe which was so
interesting it's the first time in a
billion dollars everybody's like why
would you get rid of that one like and
also Jason Momoa is like very happy
seemingly so I think all those
celebration videos were like Aquaman
free like this yeah like not Lobo at all
and then Superman Legacy because uh you
know Superman Legacy I associate that
with this Superman animated series and I
was like there's no way that they would
do because in that and the legacy of the
Animated Series there was uh it was like
dark side had uh tricked Superman's mind
into thinking he was like a child of
apocalypse and he was doing like evil
deeds and then eventually when he comes
back to Earth he's like I'm not actually
evil
um
it's gonna be the first Superman movie
um but you know the the photos that he's
pulling here from All-Star Superman yes
one of the best Superman runs of all
time his his picks like not to be uh a
selfish or narcissistic here but oh my
God I love every one of his picks Tom
King Supergirl one of the best like
Kryptonian stories period Superman or
girl or anything uh this the way they're
theoretically bringing in Hal Jordan and
Jon Stewart is a great way to satiate
the OG fans of Green Lantern but also
make sure the people that like the
modern cartoon or like the modern Jon
Stewart like Hal Jordan is a beautiful
golden age character that doesn't quite
work in the Green Lantern Mythos today
Jon Stewart is the Green Lantern of the
day so if you've got an old cop new cop
if you've got the Lethal Weapon too old
for this crap man out of time Hal Jordan
which is how I interpreted the True
Detective was basically One Cop is uh a
little removed and one cop plugged in is
how I would do it with space cops and it
also gets rid of all the propaganda of
the world and you show that people have
flaws so you got Hal Jordan maybe uh Mr
Glenn Powell and then Jon Stewart I
don't know John David Washington playing
these characters in a show where you
have the time to actually suss out what
Green Lantern should be give it the
right budget this could be the thing
from this first slate like that's genius
yeah I I think I think it was
interesting the way how he was pitching
it though because you said the True
Detective thing and I understand what
you're saying in terms of like the
characterization but the the genre in
which he was talking about it because I
think you know it's oftentimes a common
because while Hal Jordan especially can
be a lot of fun with Green Lantern I
guess I wasn't expecting such like a a
serious true investigative three thing
and I'm like that's her fascinating yeah
it's such a great approach and something
different but it also keeps that buddy
cop element that a lot of us were sort
of hoping for
um but maybe perhaps not in uh as much
of a fun thingy you know I just think
that using those two characters is
really smart because I love the whole
Green Lantern Corps there's a lot of
things to do but pairing them is a
really great way to cake and eat it too
because we haven't really had a good
sorry Ryan you know it a good Green
Lantern movie so like we need that no I
think he stands up for that movie a lot
oh yeah no he's a big fan he just
watched it last year uh and like also
the choice to have uh if you look at
this actual announcement they mentioned
just as many comic creators as tones and
they also this isn't shot this doesn't
exist they used comic book imagery which
is consciously or subconsciously gonna
finally normalize it anytime I put comic
book imagery in a thumbnail video does
garbage anytime you try to plug a comic
book it shuts down the entire algorithm
you can literally really see in some of
my videos as soon as Comics be discussed
like there's a dip comic books are why
this exists James Gunn being an actual
comic book fan means I remember like a
year ago remember when the Batman came
out and there was like those three those
those
are look at the art okay you remember
when the Batman came out and I had
plugged those three comic book arcs and
then like a week later those same three
were mentioned by DC and I was like look
they're finally acknowledging comic
books James Gunn is going to do that
from the beginning so we can finally
normalize the medium I get the comic
book adaptations our billion dollar
industry but the actual books should be
a way for people to enjoy them outside
of that two-hour window and if you if
you make this imagery a more normal
thing that's gonna just help push that
forward and I'm so excited I'm so
excited to John yes talk about the
authority The Authority I am an
authority on the authority and uh this
sounds no I mean this sounds very
exciting and and one thing I've been
thinking about is the further we Branch
out into these different comic book
universes the further we expand the
galleries that the common person is
going to be introduced to throughout
these you know like it's a dice roll and
that is both a risk but also exciting to
me because yeah this is a property this
is a series of characters that I am not
very familiar with which can often be a
risk but at the same time I think the
idea of a whole new team somebody who
can significantly come in with a
different tone this sounds like it's
going to be a darker you guys said it
has to be R-rated uh you know and
especially with all the you know sort of
looming that the Justice League and all
the sordid Affairs of the Justice League
movie had over the previous sequence it
seems cool that we would have then just
a whole new team to look at who will
have a whole new impact instead of
ramifications on this world so me as a
viewer I'm like you're gonna have to
make me care about a whole new League of
powered people in a world where there's
just tons and tons of that but at the
same time I have faith that the team
here can make that happen and I'm
excited to see what that shapes well
this team they play by their own rules
sure that's why they're the authorities
sure and that's exciting to me there is
like something they're like they're not
justice league dark but they're like a
dark Justice League yeah yeah sure I see
justice league dark maybe in the next
wave yeah anti-heroes yeah justice
league dark was like Cook and Cook and
Carol Del Toro not long ago and like if
they can do this broad of a slate then
you can actually solve a lot of the
problems of the like homogenization of a
shared Universe the big issue you're
gonna hit in in any situation like it's
the problem with like all these startups
if you think there's infinite growth
we're seeing it happen with streamers
we're seeing it happen with the internet
at large infinite growth's impossible so
when you've got a shared universe and
you think it's going to accelerate at
the same rate forever you're inherently
going to reach a point where it feels
stagnant the beauty of the Slate is
everything is so unique to itself that
you can then plug in a director's actual
Vision you can actually let writers and
directors create their own thing over
here without it feeling like it sullies
the rest and then you can choose to go
further in that direction or not like
this is an actual infinite expandable
universe as opposed to everything has to
be like remember that guy that knew
Norman Osborne everything's in the
Osborne basement like this is the
opposite if you guys are just joining
I'm seeing some of this in the chat is
that we we reacted to the video uh that
James Gunn said up front and we're just
scrolling through it then we're going to
be going through the chat in just a
little bit uh because we know we got
like a actually a fair amount of super
chats thank you guys but there's a lot
of you guys in the comments right now so
thank you so much for being here before
you hop on over to you know Grace
Randolph on Camp yeah I appreciate you
guys being here right now you stay with
us we know comics and uh so yeah sounds
like the Wonder Woman 3 movie is not
coming for sure dude I'm doing a
wonderful it's Paradise Lost as a TV
show live action uh but the pitch for
this sounds very different than that of
the comic yeah which makes a lot of
sense like I said like when I read the
when I first read the titles like I
didn't tell koi what the titles were
sitting here when I didn't tell Chloe
the titles were but I was like a lot of
these titles sound like he pulled names
from graphic novels or comic runs but
it's probably not even going to be that
even for like Gods and Monsters which is
a very Justice League kind of title
there's even an animated movie called
because this chapter is called Gods and
Monsters the DCU chapter one and there
is you guys gotta we're gonna watch it
soon I think it's like it's like the
23rd movie or something
yeah it's Justice League Gods and
Monsters which is like a uh I'll let you
guys it's like an alternate take on a
lot of the superheroes
um that's needless to say it's a very
different thing with Brendan Fraser but
um yeah but even with Paradise Lost it
sounds like a very different thing like
I is Wonder Woman even gonna be in this
it sounds like I was a little bit lost
on what he was saying like she is
because of the Paradise Island tie-in
and I do think they're going to be very
expansive but I don't feel like they'll
alienate people by having the mascara
and not feature Wonder Woman but it
could be a way to set up them as like
that's the third act like I could see it
being like a a real origin to that world
and also Paradise Lost is a legacy Arc
like a Paradise Lost is later in the
Journey of one room so I can't imagine
it starting there in the comic tradition
like you're saying it's gonna vary but I
do think it might be like Civil War
where uh in Civil War that's not the
comic book but the heart of it is still
that conflict maybe the heart of the
conflict of Paradise Lost is somehow
incorporated into this new origin for
that character I was reading um too that
he was saying how oh wait someone's
saying it's before ornament is a prequel
I missed that I was too excited yeah
yeah that's why I was like I don't think
yeah I just might as well
um well he gave a lot of praise for The
Flash movie by the way I saw that in a
variety headline that is one of like the
best superhero movies ever made
according to James Gunn another thing
that I think is really cool about the
way that this is launching where some
with the MCU specifically if we're gonna
play a little bit of a versus thing
right now even though I love the MCU
very much so you guys know this is
that the TV shows seem to have always
fought for as much of an equal
resonation in terms of connective
Universe you know what I mean and this
is kicking off with a TV show and
they're gonna and part of this
announcement of its first chapter was
the other TV shows which I think is
really cool because it's saying these TV
shows are going to be just as
significant of a viewing experience in
order to get the entire chapter versus
the show's coming later down the road
and be like people tune in for this show
and then a bunch of shows come out and
you're like where's the show gonna
matter in the movies you know you keep
saying zombie stranger
and I hope they can keep that consistent
of having the actors all be across every
medium because you know marvel has tried
that and it's worked somewhat and it's
smart to establish the else worlds up
front like make it really clear I also
think that they're gonna benefit so much
from being the one to do it after seeing
some of the things not work just on a
just on a business scale James Gunn's
been there from he kind of caused the
cosmic pivot because Guardians was so
good he was part of the brain Trust of
what a shared Universe can be but he's
also seen how Marvel has had a Disney
plus launch that was like trust us this
matters but it's over here and HBO Max
is so much more established it's more
established than even the Disney
Universe HBO exists already so you have
less groundwork to get people to
subscribe to a thing to watch your
tie-ins this feels like you're already
halfway there because of the Rd
infrastructure of HBO Max mattering of
the world so I think they're going to be
able to get ahead faster of having that
uh coordination sure true true uh
Booster Gold is a character I know that
you've been championing for for a very
very long time I think you said Zac
Efron I did would be a great Booster
Gold and I feel like he would be a
perfect Booster Gold especially for that
kind of because he's a character who has
like a a lot of ego at first and he
becomes humbled over time so he's the
one I said first when when there was an
announcement of James Gunn taking over I
said that there was going to be the the
Trinity and then some characters that
people don't know and then the weird
crazy James gun stuff well he opened
with a crazy zombie army like thing as
the first animated series but I think
booster is that great middle ground
between the James Gunn deep cut and the
mainstream in that he's a character that
could be like you know your Zac Efron's
your Glenn Powells you're you're like
handsome guy Charming but he's so Smarty
And so self-aware because he kind of he
uses social media to uh make himself
feel better about himself because he's
not a good guy everyone wouldn't be
terrible people are someone said it in
the chat no Efron will be
Zac Efron is he's too handsome yeah
people don't like him for it he's very
talented uh but he's a guy also it's a
tiny with blue beetle too it works out
perfect and if it ties on the Blue
Beetle that that's the right age you can
have him be from the future and like I
love the idea of an insecure guy from
the future coming back to get his ego
stroked being played by like someone too
handsome for their own good yeah
definitely definitely John can you
settle down a little bit more I've been
praying for Boost so we talked about
Swamp Thing we talked about pretty much
everyone right I want to make sure that
we got the chapters
well can you can you scroll a little bit
on the timeline here John
just want to make sure there's something
that's something that we have missed oh
Supergirl we haven't talked about
Supergirl woman of tomorrow I would
really want you to talk about this one
especially because I know you're a big
you were a big fan of this content this
is one of the comics that I'd like just
blindly yelled you should read this like
I think this is one of the ones where I
was like and it wasn't related to a
thing it was just like I'm so excited to
have to share this and Supergirl is a
character I think is really hard to get
right because really quick yes he didn't
specify though I mean sometimes we're
getting a little bit excited uh so I
don't know if we missed it he didn't
specify if it's going to be the same
actress in The Flash did he he did not
and she's not on like she retired from
that character but she could come back I
imagine I mean the fact that he's like
talking about the fly are we saying the
flash is ending though are you saying
it's a DC yeah exactly right so with
flash ending at season nine I feel like
uh when when they had no no no no no the
[__] the movie oh I was thinking I
mean still it's still kind of ending you
know
it's all ending it sounded when you said
the sentence made sense at the time yeah
guys this is why they gotta start over
but but no The Flash movie the the
Supergirl in there yes I don't know if
they'll use her because of the way they
phrase that ending things I feel like
they have the opportunity to have
Flashpoint and whatever stories they
launch there because you also got to
think Flashpoint uh had more Michael
Keaton stuff than Les Michael Keaton
stuff we don't know how much Ben Affleck
stuff like we don't know how flash lands
we just know that now it does in the
universe and they just did reshoots so I
could see where if they wanted a new
supergirl they could have ended that
Supergirl's take in that movie with
those reshoots and this could be a
launching point because it sounds like
they're gonna have the best of all
worlds where flash is going to end and
start things I don't know if that means
they're keeping Ezra Miller I don't know
if that means they're keeping the
actress who play Supergirl like we don't
we haven't seen it yet that said this
comic book is a beautiful way to have an
already established Supergirl that's
removed from the planet she's literally
traveling the cosmos she's basically
it's a genius story she's protecting
this girl who saw her entire family get
mowed down violently who only wants
revenge and this girl wants Vengeance
and she has this sword which is in the
image and I love that Supergirl in this
is Brusque but not uh Noble she's
willing to strike Vengeance and be
violent because she's trying to protect
the innocence of this character and
that's that perfect middle ground that
people want with Superman is there's
this thing that people want a violent
Superman but Superman is trying to
prevent others from needing to do
violence and this entire story is about
her willing to shoulder the burden of
doing this horrible thing for this
innocent girl to keep her innocence and
it's this it's only 12 issues it's very
accessible Tom King's one of the best
writers in the game and this art is the
whole way through that's not just cover
art it is a staggering bit of work I
highly recommend a woman of tomorrow so
good also it's a great commentary and
Supergirl not being called a woman woman
of Tomorrow is a play on that whole
concept it's her maturing it's a
walkabout story through violence through
Cosmos perfect yeah that's great I love
that great cell in the comments I just
pick up comic books that's a fantastic
sell on it well what I think that's cool
about it too is
with Supergirl and and Superman it
sounds like he's kind of just gonna
pluck you into their world you know what
I mean he's gonna pluck you into them
versus and some sometimes James Gunn
doesn't seem like he's too concerned
with doing like a full-on origin tale no
pearls you know a lot of these
characters like even with Guardians of
the Galaxy We're Not Really Gonna you
see how they came together but you're
not doing a complete origin for any of
those characters for the suicide squad
you're not doing a complete origin for
these characters like they're already
established now they're coming together
and it sounds like he's gonna be doing
that for Superman and it also sounds
like there'll be probably a version that
for Supergirl as well where there's
already an existence happening with them
and you might explore some of the
backstory with them like you kind of
have to
do you remember that I just had this
Epiphany because I keep looking at this
art and it keeps making me cry with
happiness uh I said the only thing I
wanted out of James gun slate was him to
reference comic book titles and not give
us too much information about the movies
he did that yeah exactly because all we
know about these is tone via comic
stories and we literally know plots but
not we'd like this is how you do a slate
like this is what I've wanted Marvel to
do for 15 years because like John gets
to be excited about Swamp Thing because
of his emotional connection to the Alan
Moore stuff but we don't know what
storyline like we have all the data we
need to be excited this is like when
they cut the perfect trailer that shows
nothing but you just feel the
emotionality like I don't know which
authority Arc they're gonna do but I
know they're making an authority thing
this is what if media companies are
going to bow down to the need to make
constant content this is how you do it
because people want stuff to talk about
this revealed nothing and everything
well and also the establishment of
Elsewhere worlds and fun and ways as as
Marvel has as the MCU figured itself out
over the course of several phases it
seemed like had a lot of James Gunn to
go okay I know how we're going to start
this then I know what I would do let's
make the TV shows definitively Canon
right up front yep and let's establish
an else worlds right up front that way
we don't have to get confused over
everything so you like that video I made
six months ago so you see Black Label
Black Label yeah they're doing it
because he even mentioned Joker in the
Batman the first two I said need to stay
over there and again that's gonna be
better than Marvel you did tell me in
private that you thought he was going to
try to roll over Robert Pattinson's
Batman into it I said they shouldn't I
said that's the one they do not do I
have it on camera
to do I said never because Robert I
don't think you did I said that doesn't
work because the groundedness of that
Gotham is the one thing that separates
it from the other gothams because
it was existing in my head because I
thought you told me no I said that's the
one thing I don't want them to do maybe
you're you're scared in the opposite
[Laughter]
about that
because the one thing that doesn't tell
me that time when we were running a test
on this thing that we were working on I
said Pattinson's Batman should never
meet Superman because it erodes the
entire psychological warfare of the
supernatural element is intelligence and
the supernatural element of Gotham is
that oh I don't say all that that's
really fancy I like I like the
soundtrack The archetypal that was all
just to get us here the archetypal thing
that makes Batman's Rogue so unique
everyone everyone thinks that Batman's
rogue's the best in comics and I agree
but the reason that in Spider-Man but
the reason they're so perfect is because
Batman's Rogues are the exact
psychological mirror to what he wants to
be if you look at Batman's Harvey Dent
that's the Justice he can't be if you
look Batman's Joker that's the chaos the
freedom of not having these rules if you
look at Catwoman that's being a thief as
opposed to being Justin good if you look
at literally all of the best characters
in Batman Mr Freeze that's hidden loving
Nora as much as Batman loves Gotham
there's a passion to his villains and if
you take away that Passion by
introducing things that are too
Supernatural and two other role in the
passion doesn't become believable to the
viewer the eye line of Pattinson is that
it feels grounded enough that the
supernatural elements of the psychology
could exist yes yes
what I'm going to be very excited about
now we're going to open up the chat in
just a sec uh what I'm going to be very
excited about too is to see how he goes
about how James got all these guides
going about and also like one thing we
have is like we have the project boss
people are vouchers start interrupt with
you betraying thinking I'm sorry
you're the shorter buff white guy of a
version of everybody
oh so when it when it comes to am I
going to have to separate see that super
Jack coming what I'm excited to see too
is how are they going to make a
clear-cut what they're going like how
you separate the Batmans because you
still have to communicate this on to a
massive audience like one thing he was
saying a while ago James Gunn when it
came to you know wanting to make sure
everything was connected is the fact
that you know sometimes even with
Peacemaker he was saying that sometimes
people come in and go wait which Joker
might be uh interacting with him though
you know like I thought they they he'll
get comments of people being confused
still about the universes so even though
he's establishing an else worlds up
front he is also establishing we're
going to make a bat family movie or or
the Brave and the Bold so how will that
be communicated and how different will
that Batman be because we've over the
years our Batman's have progressively
gotten broodier and broody
off just a Ben Affleck to Rubber Bandits
exceptionally Broody yeah and now will
this one kind of hearken back to more of
a Kevin Conrad so I think it's smart to
have a bat family situation because this
because whereas Robert Pattinson's is
very much still like year three I
imagine we're Batman yeah yeah and this
one would be way more experienced he has
the sun he's probably he's had a robin
by this point you know what I mean so
and it had a Batgirl also and so by that
point that Batman would be a very much
more mature more experienced I imagine
more of a Kevin Conroy versus a Robert
Pattinson I also think that it allows us
to explore a Batman like I said at the
top we haven't seen yet because
yeah
he's just got a bunch of the ball
are is James guns Batman does things
that HBO Max is better he doesn't do
according to Ken is anybody at all
surprised that there's no Kingdom Come
style approach to uh the resetting of I
don't know kingdoms come definitely for
Batman you see this family he's got
going on
I think that is the best version of what
you're describing without sacrificing
the tune because I do think that this
Batman can work with the Justice League
yeah I think the Justice League can
incorporate to a Batman with a family
and that's also another archetypal
parallel right like Batman never had a
family that's why Damian Wayne is an
interesting mirror to him is because he
gets to raise the child that he always
wanted to be like his his Vengeance uh
is he sees that in this this character
Damien Wings
guys in the chat do you want Finn
wolfhard to play Damien Wayne or how
about Timothy chalamet uh there is one
they're my go-to picks John is gonna I
think that's perfect there is one actor
to play Damian
are you ready are you ready Aiden
Gallagher he is already Tammy and Wayne
Aiden Gallagher yeah oh from Umbrella
Academy
he's already a seven-year-old going on a
35 year old no John it's okay
um because we should probably read some
of these super yeah new new Rockstar our
goal today was just to go live before
everyone else went live and we did was
her only goal was we got a lot of people
going live today we got to make sure we
go live before everyone else goes live
hey uh you know read the comics and the
pictures that James Gunn used this
channel so uh if you want to stick
around for some actual knowledge we got
you we got you we got you all right
let's go to the chat here no let's let's
go let's catch up on some of the supers
and we're gonna open up to the regular
uh to the just regular good old live
stream chat but but I'm like I like the
way this went because this will allow me
to go back and actually make chapters
that's nice that was the purpose of
doing those the um the live stream this
way because I was like I want to make
sure I can have a decent playback
someone can come back and watch this
yeah because I never know how to make
chapters for our lives we'll just cut
out the first three minutes when we're
all trying to get played the most
organized one that we've had here and
then yeah but that like to support chaos
being struck
Gallagher actually would be a fantastic
um that is a great pick he's got a
precociousness he's got a certain like
hoity-toityness that Damian Wayne has to
have we haven't even talked
um okay yeah comicstorians live on
Twitch not on YouTube the platform's
ours I don't know the platforms are
what's the twitch all right if you
John's getting it organized thank you
buddy sure enough we're here let's see
Eric fostering I know how's he doing
what's he talking about all righty
resident nerd man thank you for the
Super Chat uh creature commanders let's
go love James for the Deep Cuts what a
way to start us it's the deepest cut I
could not even I think that's a very
fast I was kind of hoping for a live
action take on it honestly but we might
get it if it does well if those voice
actors are cast for both well he said
animated version at first but John what
kind of creature are you hoping to see
in Creature Commandos spitball It Go I I
just want more man-bats
there we go can you get a man bad as a
creature Commando I think there's a way
to get it going let's do it you got
Ghouls and zombies and vampires Solomon
Grundy I've been reading my boy I'm
reading the comic book American vampire
recently it's great oh Scott Snyder
Stephen King yeah it's really good yeah
yeah
um let's move up here Michael Loco thank
you for the Super Chat can I feel dead
air with my pitch for DC please yeah put
it in the chat right now yes absolutely
I think yeah well the one thing about
break because I'm seeing you guys talk
about it in the chat right now the one
thing about Brave in the bold that I
think opens it up is you can get a
little bit more of your with the James
Gun World other than one of their your
weird eccentric characters like you
could get a Mad Hatter in there yeah I
don't feel like Mad Hatter would work
for the Pattinson world but that would
totally work for the brave in the Bold
world I know but also like clay face and
certain Clayface you could do Lazarus
Pit and brave in the bowl it would race
Al ghoul or Razz Al ghouls
Christopher novan likes different
that's not how you pronounce it it's
Raza
particularly like that'd be great but
yeah that's one thing too that I would
uh that I love about the separation of
Brave and the Bold and advances that you
can go with the crazier sci-fi but then
again you know you do have a you do have
uh Matt Reeves stepping in going I could
see Mr Freeze being in our world yeah um
all right let's keep it going Lion of
demise
um we haven't really talked too much
about Amanda Waters thank you for this
question
um and thank you for the Super Chat how
fitting is that Amanda Waller is a part
of Gods and Monsters LMAO yeah that is a
very fitting choice and if he seems to
really have an affinity especially for
Viola Davis is your name right yeah
he seems to have a big affinity for
Viola Davis as well like he it seemed
like when he was just you know doing The
Suicide Squad and then Peacemaker he
really wanted to make our inclusion even
expanded upon her character by having
her daughter be in Peacemaker right
but uh but he even expanded upon her
character by like making her a mother uh
something that you wouldn't really think
about with
with uh with Amanda Waller that she's a
mom yeah and so who's her husband what's
her domestic life like Batman
so yeah I think uh having Amanda Waller
show up in this uh having her is he had
this gonna be a series I think TV live
TV live action show Waller TV live which
will be an interesting like anti-nick
Fury show like kind of an anti-agents of
Shield seems like a corrupt like running
things behind closed doors but for evil
but at the same time you know like kind
of the imagery that he was flashing on
screen seemed to evoke that she herself
was having to get herself out of a ditch
yeah I mean she's handcuffed in the
image they chose yeah I definitely think
that that relates somehow to this maybe
she doesn't have the connection she's
dude she has to do it on her own yeah
I'm excited for that a while they're on
the air excited for that I'm a Waller on
the edge Mikhail wrath freaking thank
you for the Super Chat freaking
Supergirl man my favorite DC character
and the Tom King run turning into a film
man that hit me so hard so excited
sending love from the UK
I think Supergirl is going to get a
proper reinvent I do feel bad for uh
what is her name Sasha cow we haven't
even met her yet so she might suck no I
listen as in like yeah
I don't know I just I just feel like
it's it I can't imagine being an actress
cast as Supergirl than being like we're
doing a Supergirl and we don't know if
she's the same super girl but man that's
rough that is rough hopefully she can
carry on as Supergirl we'll see but at
the same time I am curious you know like
I know a lot of times you talk about the
the casting and then people get
political correct and all this stuff but
they did hire a Latina girl to be super
girl in
um The Flash movie so I am wondering if
will they just go like back to white
blonde chick and what that might be met
with you know I mean no matter what
she's an alien so it's always weird it's
always weird when that's the one people
get mad at because it's like I don't
know the skin color would be a factor
when alien like biography I think get a
Latino girl and make her play a white
blonder
let's keep this going
um the hour man John please take it away
having Damien Wayne be the main Robin is
honestly genius because we can uh then
learn about the rest of the family
retroactively just like in Son of Batman
the animated motion picture koi and I
just beheld we got a Dick Grayson at
least in that on this very Channel you
can check it out and see us get very
excited when Nightwing shows up just
like we will in the movie when that Wing
shows up Dylan O'Brien that yeah see I
like that the focus of how he pitch
Brave in the Bold is going to be on
Damian Wayne and Batman but it is going
to open up the doors to see like Dick
Grayson yeah and uh Barbara Gordon like
you're gonna see a you could see a whole
bunch of hair red hooded by that point
very well established yeah I think it's
like what they did with Daniel Craig's
bond is how do you make bond work for
today and how do you separate it from
the other bonds you go a very different
direction we haven't we haven't had a
robin since Chris O'Donnell we've never
had a Damian Wayne paternal release
relationship with Bruce Wayne we've
never seen Bruce Wayne have to be that
kind of uh relation to anyone and that
is how that Batman works with the
Justice League way more than a Robert
Pattinson Batman because he already has
to have a very different tone by his
nature
it's just perfect it's genius
um are you trying to make it bigger yeah
a little bigger all right I think a lot
of people watch this on their phones you
know yeah iPhone so we look at this John
you got this John yeah buddy for a phone
it's better you can read it better
um
let's see here bananas John take it away
I wish we would have gotten a static
shock series instead of a Waller show I
don't think her character can carry a
show I think her character can carry a
show however I am with you static shock
would be Trey legitimate and I hope that
it can happen maybe like shamik Moore or
somebody get him in there I want a
static shock movie because I I'd be
worried about the budget of some of the
imagery on a show but last of us are
showing what HBO Max is willing to flex
so I would love static shock in a way
but I'd prefer The Last of Us IP is so
massive it makes sense that you would go
like
those Saturday morning kids grew up all
right static shock has just as much but
I agree with you static shock right
around on trash can look better in a
live action I'd want to see yeah
3D that trash can is really coming at me
right now you guys know how much I love
Jessica Jones but sometimes her powers
are yeah and then landing and I don't
want static to be like and then like I
want static to be flexed well he's
already had the the animated show so
let's get a live action movie now yeah I
think a Waller series can work in an
interesting way because you have
somebody who is uniquely positioned as a
non-powered person but who has to be the
the fish out of water but the
non-awkward fish out of water constantly
wrangling and dealing with these people
should be like Daryl from the MCU yeah
but but a hard ass who knows what
they're doing yeah yeah and then I feel
like that'll give you a significant
amount to peel back in terms of
character her powers work for the budget
and that's intelligent she's got a dubla
from Dakota Jones Thank You Dakota one
virus effects for me personally Swamp
Thing and lanterns True Detective season
one uh as you say in your subsequent
comment is the still the best season of
television and I just love Swamp Thing I
feel like Brave and Bold can be Son of
Batman but better yeah yeah agreed uh
True Detective season one is so
brilliantly esoteric while giving you so
many themes if they can do something
that's like a space cop Cosmic
existential crisis that that show was
like I I feel like also swamp because he
was talking about how it's going to
focus on the horror aspects of it and
for Swamp Thing and but they've swamp
things had so many failed attempts at
this point but I heard that people
actually liked the show it's just people
weren't watching yeah the show no it had
mood in it and and was like well
produced generally and seemed relatively
did you see it uh I saw the pilot yeah
okay someone said koi for Booster Gold
and uh they got my number I'm available
but I think you know especially with
James Gunn's sensibilities on Guiding
shepherding a project like uh Swamp
Thing he would be able to I think find
that right tone for that just the right
tinge of self-awareness yeah for sure
for a monstrous creature that loves to
protect plant life like you gotta find a
a right pitch because I think if you go
like to I mean maybe I don't know I
could be very wrong that's a while down
the road if he goes like too
aggressively horror
um actually no I I actually actually I
think I'm gonna want that now that I
said I'm like it would probably be cool
to go
but for your main character you gotta
Infuse it with heart that's all I'm
getting at it is you gotta have
something Evolution there's nothing
James Gunn's done that doesn't have
heart like that's the example thing even
bright berm which is horrific has a lot
of heart he could find the tragedy
almost like a universal monster I think
you can find the tragedy behind Swamp
Thing and really focus on that versus oh
yeah Slither has has heart and humor
yeah but is also gross and icky and all
sorts super is so violent and then it's
got heart yeah and I mean Swamp Thing
you've got the the sort of tragic
elements and the ecological elements too
so there's plenty you can imbue with
emotion as well as spookiness Monster
movie Vibes the hour man thank you our
man they are introducing all aspects of
the universe the cosmic side the
grounded side and the supernatural side
this is genius genius for sure it's also
not shiny I really like that they're
showing the side of DC that isn't what
everyone's used to I like that a lot of
these characters are way swampier like
there's a lot of grit and grime here and
I think that works that's not even
mention about a Justice League you did
say that that we would get that didn't
you uh I said that the way I need to
remember what our conversation was
um
I said the best thing they could do with
bringing in a Batman was make one that
fits in the Justice League and make the
third movie in the new slate involving
the Trinity be it justice league but
establish the characters first but I
believe that if they establish an older
set of characters that's what I told you
you're [__] insane I think you're
mixing up me and Eric Voss again no no
no Cody you're thank you for the super
chat buddy koi read that please I
personally am super excited for the
Brave and the Bold as well as lanterns
it seems like they're going to make the
lantern show Amar dark and gritty
mystery which will be very interesting
and I agree because there's a lot of
crazy stuff in space who's your Hal
Jordan pick my Hal Jordan I mentioned
him for Booster Gold but my legit hell
Jordan pick which I've tweeted you can
check the tapes uh it's Glenn Pell the
band's a pilot the man looks like Hal
Jordan the man has the chin for it the
man could play a franchise for a lot of
movies the man loves comic books uh the
man is very invested you were talking
Glenn Howerton
Aidan Quinn
has an inherent charm that's got a
funniness to it like he's able to be
quippy that Jon Stewart needs and I also
think Hal Jordan has an almost punchable
face like Glenn Powell's a little too
handsome where he's got like that like
Golden Age like he's got a thing he's
got a Kendall this and I think that
works for hell Jordan that's very that's
very good Ryan he'd appreciate that
comment right guys in a good way Hal
Jordan like a like a nice guy's Ryan
Gosling yeah yeah CD Foo thank you you
always wanted a war of light and with
the slanted show confirmed I can only
pray I get to see live action atrocities
I don't know this I will fully own I
know a lot of things I actually don't
know uh the character of atrocious so
I'm gonna own that I uh I I try to I
tried it on everything such a Ron
Burgundy
I don't know this I just wanna I'm not
gonna lie and pretend to know a thing I
don't know like I've never seen someone
just say I don't know what the most the
utmost confidence
I don't know this so so all out War
fought by the Green Lantern Corps okay
yes what's a trust is the thing I don't
know atrocities oh that guy okay I do
know him I didn't know his name apology
he looks so cool and spooked yeah yeah
damn look at how cool the Green Lantern
Lord is so deep uh it is beautiful
tapestry that if they make its own thing
would be really special but yeah this
guy I know visually didn't know his name
apologies wow koi I mean it's cool
because James Gunn showed what he could
do with I mean that's the thing we keep
seeing James Gunn he will be guiding
this the same way Kevin feige's guides
the MCU but you know the thing we don't
know is like who's writing these films
who's directing these I mean we know
he's running Superman but like who's
directing these films you might be
directing supervisions reference maybe
one or two other people yeah but there's
like like in the casting there's so many
more filmmakers who are going to be
involved with this right now it's just
James Gunn that is the main creative
Association for it all but I'm like wow
who are going to be the filmmakers
associated with these projects
that are going to have to bring these to
life because at the end of the day
they'll be more involved than James and
I and like I said more comic book uh
leaning in because you can get tone
early and like two years from now when
these movies come out if you want to
read those comic books you can get the
tone now without the uh director's
attachment that's so true Alexander has
key in the chat I'm so sorry he said
Dave Batista is Damian Wayne and that
that got me John McCoy thank you for
such a generous Super Chat um I believe
gun said Justice League and Justice
League Unlimited play a large role in
shaping these plants he also did talk
about how the animated he took a lot of
inspiration from the animated properties
as well and and that's what's really
cool is going to the actual animated
department for all these things it will
be interesting to seeing how it all
unfolds I'm excited the focus is World
building and storytelling that's true
we're not it doesn't look like we're
getting a focus on I mean we didn't
really know this is if you compare it to
the MCU about like Thanos until after
Avengers yeah you know yeah what's going
to be the big Baddie what that you
unites the league essentially you know
where is that all going to be going and
I'm excited for it but you know I'd be
down some more too it was smart to not
go Peacemaker season two
The Suicide Squad don't worry those are
coming guys don't you worry Chris Pratt
he's in something I know my wife has
been unfairly getting crucified on
Twitter for no reason has she yeah man
people just attack her just because you
know she's she's uh married like he's
just gonna keep those alive because
they're so talented she just [__] the
heart of people that's the crazy part
absolutely really good because she
wasn't good at the role it'd be one
thing but like she's excellent no I see
it happen a lot usually like thousands
of tweets a day I think they're such a
good couple because it's like none of
neither of them is undeserving of their
talent and success so it's like oh good
that makes sense people are stupid yeah
get more talented if you want to
complain
but it's like gun is so much better
looking than her
he's got that white yeah
yeah yeah totally like oh man she he
really downgraded what a Victory lap for
a nerd like James got just running PC
and being like my incredible actor's
wife yeah yeah yeah
um raccoon shampoo good name here we go
gun mentioned video games again which
I'm still iffy on uh thank you for the
Super Chat by the way what characters do
you think would make the best video
games Souls like etragan make a cyborg
game ooh great question other than like
the main players of like I mean what
I've been this is the most cliche answer
you could think of but I've been looking
at those the the footage that they have
of those like unreal engines of Superman
zip around oh yeah so we're still yet to
get like a truly great gripping you can
be Superman flying around the world and
then also make it yeah but then also
make it in a way where it feels like
challenging and you have real villains
you gotta find it as opposed to just
being so super powered because I
understand the dichotomy of having
having a Superman where like oh yeah
that's great to play a SIM for like 20
minutes but there's no challenge because
you're just zipping around and I could
beat everyone yeah because you gotta
like have a balance of both but I think
if they can I I still don't feel like
we've gotten that Superman game dude
just make a game out of Superman and
Lois use all those spots
and then fight Bizarro then you're still
here and you haven't left a like please
leave a like two games I think are very
ripe for the pick and uh etragon I
actually think is one of them because uh
he's a demon you can make a horror
element game also his time would be
interesting you could have like a health
bar or after God's time as like in power
it would fade and stuff that'd be fun
a demon game yeah you know what's
popular we're gonna be like who's that
yeah you can just announced
Spider-Man on the back hear me out
with Batmobiles
the most video game friendly character
of all of them is obviously Green
Lantern because you could pick your
Green Lantern you've got all those
beautiful mythologies and then you could
also make your own Lantern and it's so
visually like the green is so uh ripe
for video game graphics and that power
like The Willpower could deplete in one
health bar your house could be another
Health part like and going to space and
flying solves the Superman thing I think
I think Green Lantern's the best game
that has been made what about an Elder
Scrolls style Wonder Woman game oh
that'd be fun too some MMO open world
swords and sand what about a Sims beach
game where it's them Escape
[Laughter]
Lewis Cox uh if Chris thank you for the
super chat if Chris Pratt is Booster
Gold who would be tet Court AKA Blue
Beetle solo maraduena sounds like sholo
is going to be I think he stays but if
he doesn't Chris Traeger himself
probably I think he'd be really bizarre
if he's not like hey we got Blue Beetle
coming out it's gonna be awesome
exciting and now we got a new blue film
new Blue Beetle to fit in my universe
well technically he's the second Blue
Beetle so they could have the original
Blue Beetle be played by a different
character
I'm just saying Garcia is that blue
unless of course we watch Blue Beetle
and then there's already a Booster Gold
like established where we just don't see
right let's get Will Poulter to play him
he's ready great he's got a warlock
yeah full of it together Jordan Garza
thank you for the Super Chat my friend
um John I don't know what that says
uh rock love you three so much I don't I
don't know what our Q is but love you
three so much just want to talk comics
and films one day so excited for James
DC we finally have hope Superman theme
plays do you all think we'll get a Mr
terrific or Miracle ever uh ever read
Kings runs and really can't wait I think
we could get Mr terrific I think
Sterling K Brown is ready for Mr
terrific that's not a bad thing Sterling
K Brown is like the Mr terrific in my
brain I had a pick in mine and then I
was like wait a minute that's a guy I
saw in the show love is blind Sterling
that's a reality show that's not an
actor Sterling Brown was my Martian
Manhunter actually oh I like that uh uh
Drax is mine uh Dave Batista is my
Martian manager because I want them to
work together again he doesn't have to
work yeah that's a smart call um I uh I
Mr terrific is one of my favorite
characters Mr Miracle the graphic novel
by Tom King and Mitch rods is one of my
favorite graphic novels of all time like
in every comic book I've read Mr
Miracles my of the ones I recommend most
I think it is a very very beautiful tale
of Being Human in a world of superheroes
especially the Golden Age of comic books
which is really hard to tell it's about
scot-free a man who can escape from
anything who's suicidal that's trying to
escape from his life while being in love
still and trying to find happiness and
big Barta is a great character it
involves Darkseid and characters that
are really really hard to grasp in a
really graspable way so I I'd always
said like a Jake Gyllenhaal type someone
that's got this really fun like dejected
apathetic thing that he can play but
he's also really charming and like
handsome and likable so he's got both
sides like he can be like yeah like uh
like the prisoners Jake Gyllenhaal meets
Love and Other Drugs Jake Gyllenhall is
my scot-free but I think that that's a
story that would be a really good thing
to do to establish the new Gods so I
like that they're doing Cosmic and
Supernatural and all that stuff here
because when you then make new Gods it
doesn't feel as alien and then you bring
in characters like Mr Miracle Mr
terrific which I do think they're gonna
do fair enough man New Gods Matthew
Cronin thank you for the moment this is
his first Super Chat he's ever sent
thank you hey well welcome thank you for
your generosity Mariah Mariah discovers
the secrets thank you Mariah the bat
family are my favorite characters in DC
and I'm so excited for a live-action
movie with a fully established bat fam
how are you guys feeling about this
that's been my dream for the longest
time like I I've always wanted to see a
Batman movie franchise evolve from like
a younger Batman I was not like you
could pick it up right after Jason
Todd's death sure and then eventually
evolve into like Old Man Batman where
he's like and then it becomes it becomes
like an Arkham no no actually it would
be like an Arkham Asylum story
yeah where he fight we're all the
villains the Rogues like that's that's
the thing you build up to but you're
also building the bat family over the
course of the franchise I always thought
would be a cool way to do it but the
other version is just started off
apparently that was Ben's movie was uh
like an escape from Arkham thing and
then uh that was also it was just too
soon
I just met you why are you fighting
everyone
a fantastic comic book um and serious
health but the con yeah yeah yeah I mean
the the game is called what's the game
called as I read the comic and the
game's very diverted it's not the same
thing at all
very existential and [__] and trippy
Grant Morris is like what it's drugs and
Arkham yeah it's an audience
I think it is uh that is you know it's a
funny uh never mind isn't it inspired
from this yes and that's an Alex Pardee
and that rainbow with the teeth the
James Gunn wears on stage sometimes is
also I didn't know that yeah in fact I I
have a version of that right here in
honor of James Gunn today sweet Alex
Pardi thank you Mariah but that family
is super excited and just to decide but
like it's like every time we've watched
one of these animated movies it seems
like it's one of the biggest like cheer
moments when freaking Nightwing shows up
like I want Nightwing so bad to have
that in a live action movie my favorite
to have like a Damien and then the the
prospect of Nightwing just show it up
and stepping in and yeah like we had the
Nightwing chest piece way back at the
Chris O'Donnell day which was the
closest we've come to Nightwing was
acknowledging Nightwing and that was
like 20 years ago so I think you put the
definitive stamp on it you just can't
stop that Jay thank you so much Jay uh
what I love
aside from Chris O'Donnell is that
they're establishing that Comics
animation TV are equally important to DC
hope everyone feels appreciated
especially the artists whose story arcs
and artworks they are going to adapt to
are problematically often left out we
don't need to pay them though do we no
no we said thanks we soon
or fight them through the premiere
what's their name nice word there if
there's a postcard I've seen people will
see yourself we don't need it we don't
need to give them any money they didn't
make the film don't you acknowledge them
don't you do it [__] but JK Rowling
deserves all the money for Wizarding
World Games
[Music]
Synergy come on guys dude let's get
Harry Potter in the DCU God yeah let's
do this standard rack clip for Booster
Gold sure and Mr terrific Danny
Radcliffe can do anything yeah let's go
hey buddy good to see you here
um you know you know yeah
this is amazing news PC comic fan what
are you predictions for the next half of
chapter one John Constantine and justice
league dark I mean the way Keanu Reeves
is talking about Constantine you said
that's I know I did that one you said
that you they think Constantine too with
Keanu Reeves might start adjusting dark
as a separate Universe I think it would
be oh that's for your I feel like they
would just keep it else worlds that's
what I'm saying a separate Universe if
you do justice league dark you gotta
have Constantine right and I would say
that you could do either one of two
things you could have Keanu Reeves
launch it so it's a team move with Keanu
Reeves which is exciting as [__] or you
could introduce Constantine as the more
British Blonde one
I feel like it would be easier to
establish an else world with Keanu
Reeves because he's not the Comic
version at all right
you can eat it too with Constantine that
would be really Supernatural as hell so
launching him all you got to do is have
Constantine meet zatana Justin and
Constantine can be a Gateway into having
it would be so easy to Fathom Keanu
Reeves Constantine having some weird
gateways yeah
and you know who Dan Stevens is standing
next to detect a [__] chimp boom
and uh yeah justice league dark
obviously we think they're building to
that I think it was really smart to not
do um to not announce a Justice League
movie right up front I mean that'd be
like coming out of the gate announcing
an Avengers it would have felt rushed it
wouldn't work this is unique here's my
one pitch for the DCU going forward five
six seven years down the line
cavil Bizarro nice nice very well done
oh what an antagonistic too I love that
do it do it light Hammer 66 this is from
a while ago when we were arguing am I
gonna have to separate you too I was
just trying to I keep looking at the art
and Grace keep your stories straight
which one of you is keep looking at the
art no no behind the scenes Greg thought
I was looking at me because I have that
habit but I was looking at the art and
he's like look at the camera and I was
like but the art is so beautiful the
entire time I'm looking at the super
chat's even looking at yourself do I
have it I know for sure watch it I was
like Greg knows all I know you think
I was going to bring this stuff
I'm gonna Reserve this look at the back
right now you think you know your
eyeliner
decides to bring this up you know
whatever observe as much as this man
observed we would never really argue on
camera just off you [__] imagine if
we had a livestream would be really fun
yeah
replay value off the charts yeah No
One's Gonna accept
[Music]
is an amazing human being I love the
hell out of her thank you heather for uh
contributing here thank you sending you
love hope things are okay at home Kawaii
Nancy thank you so much hey yeah hi yeah
I love these things thank you Kawaii
Nancy very Rupert Jamison denim nerd
says gun is writing too much thoughts no
uh they're just planning and reviewing
somebody's writing Superman I think
we're writing everything yeah that's
just Superman he's writing as far as
what they've announced Kevin feige is
writing too much
yeah I think this is a good pick uh I
like I I don't think he's gonna I don't
think he's writing too I'm writing too
much James Gunn seems like you sure
denim nerd said the words writing too
much or maybe they meant revealing like
I don't I don't do the healing too much
yeah either way I disagree I mean it
seems like there's he laid out a slate
and they have a plan for the next eight
to ten years but it seems like you could
easily slip things in between and sort
of adjust as you go with what they
announced at least here now you gotta go
to the CH I want to see the regular chat
for a second yeah
go to the bottom yeah where are we at
um
yay refresh yeah he wrote All a creature
Commando as well oh he wrote all the
creatures he said he was writing he's
also he's also doing a peacemaker he's
also got a little movie called Guardians
3 coming out yeah I mean she's gonna be
such a weird press Tour on that James
Gunn yes it is it seems like the kind of
guy though for whom things again
um yeah okay uh he like look at the way
Peacemaker float like flew out of his
pen like he was just like I just sat
down and then all of a sudden the series
came out he seems like a guy who's like
always riding and for whom just ideas
Flow Free so I I don't think he's
writing too much we look like the most
uncomfortable group in the world look at
us right now well you're not supposed to
see our legs imagine taking the
screenshot of us in that moment
I'm like coward behind this laptop
all three of us just like we don't want
to have a camera in pointer spoiler
alert gaming chairs aren't comfortable
[__] awkward
also I like I crossing your legs looks
so weird I want to get a new chair
crossing your legs looks so weird on
camera but it's way comfier in these
chairs but then I feel like I'm like
contorted oh look at us yeah look at us
I refreshed that one last time and then
we'll catch oh oh yeah yeah because
we've got a couple coming in here thank
you guys for being contributing to the
stream by the way
is there also that other thing or is it
just all this is catch-all like is it is
uh like streamlab super chats there's
just super chats is it streamlabs oh
yeah let's uh while John's pulling that
up uh James gone on Zachary Levi's
recent controversial tweet I can't be
changing my plans all the time because
an actor says something that I don't
agree with
which is what he tells people at Marvel
all the time about Chris Pratt I take it
sure he's a great guy he's he's hard
it's a great place I still like Chris I
wonder what I'm on screen uh I and like
I wonder why this dream please people
think I wonder what they're gonna do
with Shazam too no matter what like that
feels like it's one of the ones that's
kind of on the edge and I don't think it
has anything to do with the tweet I just
don't kill me it's before Flashpoint uh
I mean I think flashpoint's gonna be the
determining factor for how all this
reset uh moves forward hyper Gooch thank
you so much for the Super Chat people I
think DC fans didn't win by the way my
name Ethan lost her thank you for being
here well Tyler hawklin hoklin hecklin
hecklin played supplement and uh
upcoming movie Superman
um
giving his Delight well I think the
benefit of what Tyler has right now if
they want to keep Superman and Lois
afloat is that that's already
established as part of like not even
even a part of like it's technically
consistent with the other arrowverse
shows but it's already established me
it's like own elseworld's thing yeah
it's like you can just travel through a
portal and get get to that world but but
it's already it's known it's not the
same Superman as the same Earth where
you know the arrowverse mainly resides
at uh so I I think they can keep that
show alive but I don't think he would be
the superman but that would be great
he's a fantastic pick I've been trying
to get Court to watch that show forever
oh dude they've got Michael cudlitz to
be like Luther yeah that's a great pick
I'm very excited I'm trying to get a
quarter watch your man Lois it's
seriously it's a great show I think
you'd really love it and it would be
everything every criticism you've ever
had about Superman it is there if you'd
like me to watch it on real Rejects and
react leave a comment below they don't
get the numbers even when it's John and
I uh oh so oh even when it's there yeah
they still got like a year or more for
season three to drop maybe if the stars
align we can all three uh stubble
mcshave if Lo thank you for the Super
Chat Robo is a part of a movie series
which one super girl just just cram him
in there as her sidekick it doesn't have
to make sense it could be in a post
credit
of that world because if she's traveling
through space trying to defend the honor
of someone going to meet all these bad
people in different Corners there's a
mercenary out in space that's done some
messed up stuff that might relate to the
big bad because I don't want to give
away who the big bad is because I think
it's really special in the the Tom King
run but at the very end a mercenary that
could know that big bad could be Lopez
like it actually could work that would
work and I still think Jason Momo could
be Lobo he's so made up you could you
could do it
thank you so much never sent a super
chat before well good I'm a proud reject
Nation member just say citizen
I'm a proud United States of America has
support with this first chapter being
Gods and Monsters what do you think is
the plan for the chapters Beyond
I mean that's a really I mean we've kind
of talked a little bit on that but koi
what project do you do you really hope
gets pushed I mean I do want a Nightwing
movie I would like a I think Nightwing
it's some still for some reason like
people love him but never got it still
doesn't quite get to respect I feel
Nightwing deserves and he is the [__] I
feel like that is the best grounded
character that hasn't gotten the love so
I think that's very important for the
next wave but I honestly think the way
they go is they build out and then they
kind of come back together for New Gods
and I think that like the thing that
makes DC so interesting is these big
Supernatural elements with Cosmic that
like Marvel's got Thanos but the dark
side element has so many like pieces
that build to that so I want a Mr
miracle I think the most because it's
kind of like Nightwing in Cosmic like
there's a grounded Supernatural to him
and I think that's DC's like bread and
butter see I think it would be sick to
do a Nightwing movie where it's like you
already have it seems like they're
already gonna have your bat family
established so you could tell the Dick
Grayson Nightwing origin you could have
him as Robin on screen via flashback or
something like that and intertwine that
with a present day Nightwing story and
get the best of both worlds I also think
bloodhaven needs to be introduced and
they mentioned bloodhaven in the Batman
I'd love to see Nightwing get his own
time in this new universe and have it be
the storyline Tom Taylor's doing where
he he gets Alfred's money when alfredize
Polar alert Alfred gets killed uh and
basically he does whatever he's always
wanted Batman to do which is like put
the money into the City and you see the
corruption of like what it is to try to
help the infrastructure financially so
it's a really interesting commentary on
Dick Grayson doing that which Batman
never did because he doesn't have the
same trauma that Batman has but it's
also like how that also doesn't work so
it fixes a lot of plot holes of Batman
while making Nightwing his own thing I
realized this but goofball pointed out
that this color symmetry is the
Nightwing symmetry finally yeah it is a
comic book chair Garth thank you
McMurray thank you for being that's a
good point Coy I'm glad Gunn didn't just
use uh semaphore Flags
Swamp Thing Batman and Robin Superman
and Supergirl hearken back to the 80s
and 90s movies uh I joked that we don't
know the format this is going to be so I
said it might be carrier pigeon or a
fleet of foxes and that is a play on
that and I would have enjoyed some Flags
some Super Chat chips as Batman no no
love it I think Jackson Ackles would be
a good Batman actually he might be the
right he's the right age
loves the character voice I think it'd
be great a lot of people there was a
conversation in the chat where someone
said Jensen Michaels was overrated and I
was like everything in my power to not
just jump in there that's like just not
I love having like a little comment once
in a while that acknowledges direct
regularly we got you regular job and now
where they're like oh they are listening
crap the last domain Plastic Man is the
one announcement I was hoping for that
we didn't get because Plastics man had
been in development forever and they've
actually had scripts and development for
it and I do think that's a James Gunn
character like that world I think he's
coming uh al-renshaw which of these
projects you think will be rated are
authority authority authority has to be
rated R and I feel like gimme Swamp
Thing or art was Swamp Thing I
depending on the budget because yes
I think Waller show for sure would be uh
R-rated in in uh for whatever television
is like what are you doing HBO does that
TV MA yeah that's what it is yeah
because they still have I don't even pay
attention
I just watch TV yeah HBO still is
broadcast on televisions I just watch
stuff I'm like oh this is violent
that's true that's a great part we're
all choosing the chat the DC owns all
these characters for film rights so they
can do what Marvel couldn't yeah and TV
characters back yeah it's true that's a
great point I'll trade you ego for
negasonic like those conversations don't
happen Michael Loco here's the pitch
thank you Michael look I remember you
said I feel the dead space with the
pitch DC does Things based on different
crisis events this way you can have the
Side Stories linking the what ifs and
change the cast of your crisis so that
we also get new interpretations of the
characters very similar to what you have
said before I think they have a more
established way to go out and in and
implode and contract their Universe
whenever they want like also like Batman
and establishing an elseworld at the
jump talking about how he made the bat
family oh I see it's Contracting and
people die and then he goes back but
like the way uh they're establishing the
else Worlds at the top means they can
have more Canon they can literally
recast as needed they can do Side
Stories as needed they can literally
have multiple you could have multiple
Green Lanterns in Canon and out of can
like it allows for all the things and
directorial freedom with elseworld so I
do think a crisis is going to clean
things up that's why they exist in the
comic books and James Gunn is following
the blueprint I've never understood how
people don't look at comic books coming
out monthly and go this is serialized we
should do movies and shows Disney
finally did but they're starting a
universe with serialized content that
has in and out of Canon because he's
trusting in the audience and he's
following the blueprint of the comics
these are based off of Genius crisis oh
I think conceptually and sometimes you
can read a comic like conceptually the
idea is like perfect but you know like a
lot of these Comics do not translate
like you can't just go let's just do
exactly this comic yeah everything is
Sin City you know most aren't not
everything should be yeah most aren't
also what do you call Batman skips
church every Sunday Christian Bale thank
you Vegeta holy [__] that's a good one
that is a good one
that's an amazing that's amazing yes I
love that I've never heard that that's
good and thank you alrensha for uh
defecting from campia and being here TJ
Perry from from our old school days
that's my camping impression half
half-hearted camping impression and our
first topic today
my favorite YouTubers I'm gonna repeat
myself
I'm gonna repeat myself
he is a talking he's so tall TJ Perry
what's up dude homeboy from St Charles
my favorite YouTubers koi I did a tiger
woods-esque fist pump when guns
announcement referenced the comics
they're based on and then I cheated on
my wife yes
I had a sex addiction
and I went broke because I spent all my
money yeah
Wikipedia comic fans I uh I I made a
video calling out Wikipedia host because
I said that this would be the way ouch
the way that James gone there's too many
of us out there what are you doing man
someone called me an elitist because I
suggest people read
um but other I think the thing that
James creating is the tool of the rich
proletariat book no but the way that uh
the way that people uh can can actually
reward the work is people that have read
the comics will have an advantage in
commenting on it like us here uh you
guys have read some of the books I've
recommended you check out and like we
can talk about it but all these people
that are like oh what's that I gotta
look it up they're gonna be behind
because they're only gonna have the
cliff notes which anyone can acquire I
do think there is a reward to actually
doing the work and then you're getting
your expertise from experts as opposed
to getting your expertise from someone
yelling excitedly on Tick Tock you know
what it's a beautiful thing thank you my
main issue is I have a hard time
remembering
like that's the [__] I'm always like I
did read that what's it called I'm not
saying that other people shouldn't make
content I'm just saying if you want
expertise it should be from people that
know it versus people that pretend to
know it that's my only issue so thank
you so much to know I've been reading
more graphic novels lately well I mean
the authority is a great example and
like America novel what was it before
Authority storm something Shepherd storm
watch storm watch
four I was like there was something
before I started watching that was that
ice cream Brothers told you I don't know
[__] man no no it's just titles you know
Clark Kent I want the Justice League
back
if you're still here please leave a like
there's no way they won't that's a very
ironic name to have between your Justice
League my friends can you guys tell me
how the uh streams for new rock stars
and John campy and Grace Randolph are
going so good have you seen Paul's video
uh heavy spoilers I hear it's a good one
uh just plug other YouTubers that's what
I do
oh hey what's up thank you
well they make a Teen Titans you think
how about Blue Beetle ooh that would be
interesting I feel like that would be on
the reserve for a while because I think
I don't know how much they really give a
[__] about this stuff but they're
evidently building up Young Avengers and
so part of me is like they want to like
kind of not want to have your Teen
Titans thing come out around the same
time you're I mean I think down the road
you'll get it long story short yes I
think down the road you will get Teen
Titans it's the central part of many of
these characters yeah make a runaway
Style Like Teen Titans especially like
Robin's Journey before becoming
Nightwing he was a member of the Teen
Titans he went to the movies and I think
Beast Boy and those characters are very
beloved and haven't had their film live
action yet so I think that's like you
know I want to see Raven you want to see
those characters he sneakers season two
is shelved FYI no no no he wouldn't do
that his hot wife is on that
shows
thank you Francesca I'm pretty sure the
show is going to be the trial of Amanda
Waller uh it's just going to be a legal
drama She-Hulk will show up her ruthless
sister
it's gonna be a urge you want to get
laid on Tinder uh I wonder what
characters will be involved will he pull
from his Suicide Squad oh definitely
swiping on Tinder it might just be the
suicide squad versus Amanda Waller I
would I would love to see The Suicide
Squad like getting their revenge like on
Amanda Waller controlling them and it
might be like that situation where she's
feeling the comeuppance uh but I also
think it'll be a place to have some fun
cameos like Sean Gunn played um calendar
man and I think that characters like
that would be a great place to put him
in this world I think to a polka dot man
show come on
one-off movie it's like a weird one-off
animated movie
style yeah yeah something really bizarre
and strange Jack Sampson thank you for
the Super Chat I think um I think Reeves
Batman is so special and I hope a new
Batman doesn't overshadow Pattinson and
create audience bloat jdw for Jay
Stewart and Harvey D that's a cool jdw
John David that's what I was saying John
Stewart I agree yeah sure uh Pattinson I
think is is playing such a different
world that it won't conflict because
again choosing the Batman that already
has Damian Wayne establishes an older
take it establishes a more in the world
Batman which is better for the Justice
League I think Pattinson's Batman gets
to stay a David Fincher movie because of
this announcement I was afraid without
another Batman that they would try to
blend Pattinson as my concern was but
also it would kind of um muddy the water
so if you keep it over here at the
penguin show all that stuff can exist
separately as an else world so I think
this Batman announcement is actually
better for Pat Pattinson's Batman to
exist but yeah then you can get
something you were looking at yourself
oh I was that time that was totally true
only that time I mean that time I'll
acknowledge it that time I'll I'll give
you the credit for noticing that time
it's been going on for I just wanted to
wait it's you see yourself moving and
it's distracting you're just like how do
you not you're talking to a mirror I
love it I'm used to that like how do you
not see it there's a giant screen the
screen is what 40 inches how do you not
see yourself moving I learned from John
with everyone here and I see shiny
objects you sons of [__] right now
now koi's out of focus you can't see his
beautiful self now but if I get closer I
can well look at me you know what it's
shy
with a red coat behind me this
development all of this
is my feeling origin stories
becoming the mirror man as much as I
love a dark and they don't I don't think
do they know what we're talking about
here we have a monitor here we should
see ourselves here right yeah it is a
tiny little lens so if you record a
video on your phone are you looking at
the Le the camera or you're looking at
yourself as much as I can I'm looking at
the camera but I keep seeing me and it's
distracted yourself I try not to most of
my YouTube videos like two eye lines
it's very distracting I'm working on it
I know it's a cop no I'm just giving you
[__] A lot of people do it most people
do it and I'm not exactly
very hard quickly to the tune of
audience float sorry to the tune of
audience blow as a viewer I am excited
for the prospect of what this new BET
take on Batman will be because I feel
like this will be an opportunity I love
a gritty grounded Batman as much as
anybody I loved the Batman but I think
this will be a nice opportunity to bring
some of the fantasy some of the heights
some of the Towering Deco Gotham back to
Batman and that will suit the shared
Universe in a way that will then
contrast very nicely from we're gonna go
sit in the rain for three hours and be
very grounded take you know yeah so I
think that will be nice thing and it
will probably Bridge some of the Gap
where it'll take like the best of the
things the Schumacher movies tried to do
and then they'll cram it into the
darkest point snap who
that took a while longer than I expected
it's happening it'll be announced worlds
they'll spend Millions upon hundreds of
millions of dollars on that for dozens
of people to enjoy yes all dozens dozens
I like the Steiner version
I think it could work that's the thing
is elseworlds anything goes that's the
thing that gun set himself up for is I
think I'm still holding on 10 15 years
bring back bat Fleck and make him do
that also bring back Kingdom Come Henry
Cavill make it like there's totally an
option for it if the people that wanted
it so loudly weren't so aggressive about
it and how they deliver the message that
is a cool message that is not an example
of what you're talking about
I don't know snap who I just see Jesus
freaking Christ when a beautiful slate
was announced someone complaining about
something from the past well snafu
you've created a real snafu in this
conversation let me tell you Brandon
Joseph thank you for the Super Chat Gunn
also opens a lot of possibilities bat
family his family Waller's Network the
creature expanded Network Etc all
established off screen so they exist
the best world building to me is when
um like I I I like I think about when I
was first watching the Mandalorian and
sometimes they mention like planets and
[__] that I that I was like I don't know
what that is I don't know what that is
but I'm still so invested in the show
and I think that's a part of what the
experience will ultimately be like not
like a bunch of wink and nods kind of
like the name drop of bloodhaven and
Batman and the Batman where it's not I
love that bloodhaven
yeah they did it they didn't make it it
was a sentence like I'm going to Boston
it just makes it feel lived in yeah and
I think that's how a lot of these
references will feel just like lived in
versus the turtles the moment that drove
me crazy was like I knew Thor growing up
and I was like we get it like I love
that eternals felt separate and so they
were like this is in the MCU like let
these things screw Marvel woman right
guys am I right separate them complaint
about the eternals from Koi
screw the MCU we all hate that we all
hate Marvel now it has been uh lying
about his opinion on eternals I just
want to say yeah yep and the Irishman
too raccoon shampoo thank you raccoon
for being back here so if the flash is
the reset we got like a 50 Super Chat I
saw everyone like where's that 50 one I
want to otherwise we don't get it I want
to retract I want to be able to see what
it is
so if the flash is the reset button is
Aquaman 2 in the Deku but it's a sequel
to the dwe film so it's Aquaman won
retroactively in the DCU I think
flashpoint's gonna answer that uh I also
think that the reshoots they did with uh
Ben Affleck are an interesting question
because they were still shooting Aquaman
2 while this stuff was like not yet
firmed up so I don't know how they're
going I think they'll be reshoots I
think flash is going to decide a lot
firm up
firm up that's very that's a great Point
that's a fantastic Point
um Nathan palia
crazy this is only part one
this is a really great question about
the awkward though because yeah I think
it's really like that movie's out in
December for a reason I kept saying that
flash needs to come out in December to
reset everything yeah now I think it's
very interesting that they kept the
Slate the way it was and that allows
Blue Beetle to be a maybe kind of launch
point but a soft launch into what
Aquaman is and I think that Aquaman
coming out five months six months after
flash gives them a lot of time to make
it in or out
yeah they probably filmed a ton and a
lot of it's filmed in the lot because
the nature of Aquaman is underwater
obviously yeah so you can film it
privately like you can do reshoots
without and like Mamo is clearly on
board because he's making like Instagram
excited videos so like I think it allows
for a lot maybe that Excitement Video is
him being like I get an extra million to
do as many reshoots as they want like it
could be anything so I think that really
behooves people that want the universes
that they love to continue to see those
four movies I think it was very smart if
James got to address at the top I think
they need to make it so people want to
see those movies because there's this
weird thing where people are like these
two hours don't matter it's only part of
a shared Universe go to the movies that
you want to support and that'll help it
be in the DCU if you want it to be was
it hard looking at the camera it was so
hard
I feel your pain I feel your pain
crazy this is only a part of chapter one
I know it's a pretty it's huge the thing
is if it was like I've just announced 11
movies that would be insane but the fact
that some of them are TV shows helped
spread it out yeah it feels like like an
early announcement like there are easily
more things that could be on the Slate
there you know it's more than I expected
it's a lot more than I thought I'd be
like [__] [__] thing I was thinking
three I thought one obscure one
mainstream and one James gun cut like
yeah I wasn't like oh wow this is like
Superman Batman like this is everything
yeah we kept going the video six minutes
I was like what's he gonna talk about
don't forget about the four we got
coming out this year yeah
uh phase and uh Khan uh thank you so
much hi guys big fan of your channel
when do you think Darkseid will be
introduced and how do you reckon James
Gunn will introduce him first thing
um yeah uh that's a great question what
do we have on the Slate here
not Paradise Lost for sure I don't I
think it won't be in this first chapter
no I don't know it's too fresh and
everything but he's got to be part of
the super it could be something to do
after super like around Supergirl time
if they wanted to do it in this first
chapter but I think there's going to be
something other than the fact you have
Superman I think it's gonna be
intentional staying away from Snyder
versus stuff for a while yeah but I
think um yeah I know I think you gotta
have it be with a because dark side is a
Justice League level threat you know and
so we gotta have it be there I think
it's really smart that James Gunn said
that Lois and Jimmy are going to be in
Superman because that establishes a very
earth-based Superman and that Supergirl
is doing a cosmic story because that
establishes them being as very different
characters and therefore I think you
could start to plant seeds of Darkseid
in both giving you the scale of concern
on Earth and giving Supergirl but you
also don't have to because of that
Duality so I wouldn't but I do think
they can if they want to because Jimmy
still gonna be a CIA operative and be
killed immediately Nathan Nathan shut up
everyone's shut
since DC is about Legacy and history
which is what DC stands for actually if
you didn't know need Teen Titans uh and
Young Justice after Maine Leaguers are
set successful static as DC's main teen
hero
wow there's a lot of like random love
coming in here for the Teen Titans and
Young Justice right now it's static
shock I mean the love has always existed
I'm just saying like I wasn't expecting
that to be part of the conversation
today uh so much but I guess this is
what people want I want only team
listening yeah I think that the audience
is you know uh well yeah right now oh
yeah but I think there's two very
different sets of DC fans people that
grew up when DC was already making
movies and then people that like had the
Batman movies like I want more and so I
think the people that grew up with the
Schumacher Batmans are like now making
them like we've become the suits like
there's people in power that grow up
with them and I think those people had
kids that knew Teen Titans so I think
that's their Justice League so I think
that they're going to appeal to those
people soon because like I said now the
suits the people that are making these
decisions are having kids like those
people are gonna want their kids to have
their Heroes on screen that's why you
see all these you know Avengers making
these movies that are like oh and uh the
young Avenger like they're they're
making movies that they want their kids
be able to enjoy Teen Titans is that on
audience I think it's coming
Garth Mick what's going on here John
Garth McMurray video game idea space
cavi in a Grand Theft Auto Style game
Lobo right there that's crazy
and Lobo and Santa killed Santa once
yeah sure oh that's that's reference I
want that elseworld so bad Lobo kills
Santa Barbara playing Santa yeah Shepard
intolerant thank you maybe we see
brother I with paranoid Batman
I think Hugo Strange would be a great uh
way to bring in uh brother I the this
whole world of Arkham and I think Hugo
Strange be a really fun villain also a
great choice for Dave Batista I think
you guys figured I kind of want to Hugo
Strange reserve for patterns to be
honest yeah yeah I think he suits that
world really well still put Batista in
there I'll say you go straight and be
fun to see a pop-up in a joke or two
with Harley Quinn yeah like the
psychological element yeah also that's
how you Brendan swamp things also Swamp
Thing we just made the Hugo strangers
Universe
crazy experiments all the time you go
strange turns runs and smiles at camera
and every post predacing like Thanos
pradineski
um uh sorry if I missed it but did you
see the next Matt Reeves Batman is
called the Batman part 2 and releases
October 3rd 2025. I missed that no what
a title did that really happen
I'm excited 2025. that's way too long
that's a wait he's already well [__]
takes his time with him it's almost like
he makes sense it's like he's very
measured and considered when he makes
these well we'll also have the penguin
show in 2024 I imagine because they
started filming that like in two weeks
that's true we'll have that as a Gateway
and then that'll probably because I hear
the Penguin shows like the penguin um
trying to take the the remnants of
Gotham and build an Empire and they're
gonna have flashbacks and stuff so maybe
uh because she didn't give any mention
of that in this thing same I was a
little worried when he didn't but I
think that will be leading into the
Batman like it might go Batman one
Penguin Batman two true true so maybe
that's why it's 20 25 if that's true so
enough all right trash boats I want a
specter
inspector love for Specter I want my
ghost cup let's do this for some reason
I want Victor
um
green lighted
and then Bob chapek we could get him in
there I think Specter can work now that
you've introduced Hal Jordan and like
the third of course it would be very
interesting to do like a specter show I
don't know if a specter film will work
but I think Spectrum I think like a dark
Jordan would be cool to journey into
sure yeah especially if he's the
McConaughey of the True Detective Duo
I'd love like an esoteric like weird
Meandering Specter all right here we go
there it is
on the ones and twos
[Applause]
yeah there's seven people in here
let's modulate our voices next let's do
chipmunks
wait are we normal voice we are normal
boys
when I got on scn that one time I was
accidentally in it was uh I think I
think it was like this voice
and then I learned how to turn those off
a long time and they could not tell if
it was a bit job I have no idea no idea
was turned on oh I love that too so much
he was doing that for someone
yeah like it's just talking sincerely
and they were just cracking up and he
had no idea yeah it was like what a
weird joke
what's wrong with me anyway he says
they're so jolly let's hope this paved
the way for a Constantine justice league
dark movie Series game Constantine in a
lot I mean especially for justice league
dark you got to have Constantine in
there and he's like in some ways
considered the
some people might say like Captain
America is the leader of the Avengers
but then there's Iron Man right who
keeps it together and funds it exactly
there's a there's a leader on the field
and a leader there's the genius
exactly
Constantine I think is going to be our
our eye line because he's always kind of
more I want a guy Richie actor uh for
Constantine I want a very guy I mean
no but imagine like a guy Richie Justice
League
Now's the Time Man from Uncle is just a
hard Army Hammer and whoever's asking
for Rick and Morty reactions now is also
the time
all your dreams will come true but I do
think that could be a whole corner of
the Universe I agree with that Santa
Monica in there dude I've been wanting
Zatanna for like 10 years so they've
been talking about making zatana very
very quickly is that that's part of the
past that's not part of any of this new
[__] that'll be re-contextualized by
James Gunn we should assume if you look
at what Sony's done with all the things
they almost made with Sam Raimi they've
done that with the uh Tom Holland and
like as you remember Spider-Man 4 was
going to be vulture I think a lot of
times Studios have a script and they go
like what did we almost do and then they
picked the things that work because
Mysterio was almost like a thing in the
Samurai and then we got Mysterio if you
look at corvius was almost a thing so I
think that Studios and Marvel like they
joked about serpent society and like
that's a rumor right now that we're
gonna get them like I think that they
plant seeds and then to see if it works
so I could see uh satana being a rumor
that then gets folded into the new thing
and make it work so I want it I think
that's gonna be Katana a whole corner
thank you so much for such a generous
Super Chat that means the world eyes
uh thank you the stream is making my
work day so much better thanks for all
the awesome content guys thank you for
being here and there are people just
showing your support there are people
it's interesting like 2500 how many
people are still here John uh over uh 2
800 actually no actually three thousand
thirteen people wow thank you everybody
all of you left a like
come on come on uh
almost if if uh if 200 odd more of you
leave the last 10 viewers we just yeah
we just asked I'll I'll wrench uh uh if
you think Ezra will be back you are
crazy uh I don't I don't I I think it's
we get to be assessed I think I don't
see how that uh probation goes I don't
think they were going to
here's the thing
I feel like the decision with Ezra has
already been made whether or not Ezra
will stay
I don't if Ezra is indeed not going to
stay I feel like they would wait to say
that till after the movie is out that
way people are like this is pointless
what's the point of watching this we've
heard so much of that already uh with
all four of the properties so I feel
like they're gonna try to get you know I
think with
um the way how a lot of actors have been
canceled or fired I just feel like maybe
Ezra Miller situation makes a lot of
sense if Ezra Miller you know probably
was treated equally instead of just a
500 payment and a year what's that is
that the thing I forgot what it was I
had like a small rotation I never really
been yeah I lost track of I got I got I
got I was like hey I'm just so sick of
talking about this for some probation
some community service
there's been a lot of Ezra videos we
could have still done but I was like a
lot of people have made bought houses
off I don't want to do them anymore
yeah we'll see what happens but I'm like
I'm running out of stuff to say this is
ridiculous maybe don't keep this person
in a major franchise Blockbuster we
don't need to talk about Kevin trash
boat I sent a two dollar super chat but
I like a spec okay
DC Direct animated short okay fair
enough and I also want a big Killer Croc
and huge Bane please Killer Croc is the
kind of thing that will work in the
brave in the Bold yeah 100 that's the
beautiful thing about separate that's
why I love that concept because of the
fact that like you can do a huge
actually yeah a more accurate Bane yes
would work for brave Luchador oversized
oversized Venom juice yeah like go all
out but also intelligent you can do both
yes when Bane is dumb it's completely um
yeah but Killer Croc
um I think would be yeah if you can
bring that to life that would be
incredible didn't that movie win an
Oscar
nominated did It win did it either way
can you move the numbers over here so
you guys don't even know what I'm
talking about yeah I just don't want to
see that
then I'm like oh how many people uh
looking at yourself in a giant screen
it's distracting
um okay we're fine it did yes all right
sweet all right let's uh but yeah I
think a big Killer Croc will be
incredible uh I I mean Killer Croc is
not like
he's like a bit of a mobster yeah yeah
but he lives in the sewers yeah he's
like he's got uh I want him to be just
like that in the movies
that's I've always heard as well I see
I'm a Killer Croc scram
you're gonna be swimming with the fishes
and me yeah in this tunnel
concrete love is Batman
where's that movie dan v900 well that's
the other thing too is there's stuff
that no one would think about but like I
would love a period piece or something
Gaslight man goth my gas light you can
also do some Samurai one because of
elseworld you can do Superman red Sun
you can do all sorts of stuff dude and
Dan v900 agrees thank you for being here
Damien being the Robin is a big
disappointment for me I have to get a
good a different opinion here I have a
bad feeling we won't get Tim who is a
better character Superman Legacy makes
me think we will get John Kent it's a
very good slate though I think we'll get
Clark I think we're gonna start off with
Clark for Superman Legacy and I feel
like Tim would already be established
um I think you can go back and sort of
explore these where would Tim be by that
point in the Damien story uh because it
goes It goes I mean it could be
nightmare Jason Tim yeah Jason the movie
Dead Tim would be probably uh you know
upset with Batman and doing his own
thing like kind of running around
because they're not like he he retires a
lot he quits a lot well they all do uh
and then Damien would have to like deal
with that like you know surrogate son
element with Tim so I could see Tim
being like the big brother that like is
reluctant to let him in like in the bat
family yeah but you see the thing the
thing about it too I feel like it's
easier to get on board with a
live-action Robin now because because
Robin can be a bit of a debatable
subject but especially when you're doing
like a young kid yeah I think it's
easier to sort of get on board when it's
like we've already established that
we've had Robins before and it's his son
and that just makes for a different that
makes for a more interesting different
side of Batman than we've never seen
because he has only seen surrogate
father or adopted right we've only seen
dab we haven't seen like this is my
biological kid right here right and
that's a hole he has from losing his
parents that we don't really address
other than the flashbacks well I think
that conscientiously gives you the
function of a robin character but solves
the ward problem because that just
doesn't happen and now whereas if it's
his actual kid and I get there's a
scrappy dooness to Damien Wayne to a
certain degree as a character but I
think you could fix that too but also
Damien's a character you have to reel in
from like don't become the thing I'm
always fighting yeah right right yeah my
darkness yeah so like the the morals and
lessons imposed by Batman I think will
come from trying to get his own kid to
like don't cross yeah I mean I think Tim
is the good Robin Dick is the one that
left and and like you know the
cautionary tale is dead so like you've
got all these different elements Tim
doesn't go away because Damian exists no
exactly no they'll still exist
um Despair and ruin getting midnighter
and Apollo the best same-sex coupling
Comics is amazing Billy Eichner as
midnighter and Matt boom Boomer that
Bomer what do I know that name from he's
an American Horror Story a bunch people
ornament Superman for a long time real
handsome
very symmetrical face yeah you've seen
Matt Bomer
yes yes yes yes yes yes in time yeah
there's a there's a movie
I I do I've seen all of American Horror
Stories so I know this face but I'm like
isn't there another movie it doesn't
matter I love him as and that also is
fun to play with the Superman thing like
I love when there's casting that's like
oh you're a commentary on so I love the
Apollo midnighter combo there that's fun
oh but Billy Eichner I I actually really
liked Bros
I don't think Billy Eiger could do it
sure I don't know his work other than
the Billy on the Street stuff so I I
feel like pen Bros I like Bros but like
it's way more heart than I expected like
that rom-com's got they cared uh but
yeah I think uh a ROM come with heart
what only Crazy Stupid Love and Harry
Met Sally and now Bros never seen either
of them
movies all three of them you seem like
crazy Blue Valentine those are my
breakout movies nope damn it okay we got
it we'll go let's cry the blue votes you
me Gosling and Michelle Williams all
right dead shot once we answer that
question
uh yes
uh dead shot John take it away I want to
see a Batman movie with red hood as an
antagonist but also can't believe we're
getting Damian Wayne glad they know to
go mature with projects I feel like red
hood it would exist at this point in
time though chronologically yeah maybe
that's the villain or in the background
like maybe it's a setup for the sequel
what if they just like totally [__] us
over we can totally dig us over and they
never had a Dick Grayson it's just
straight to David he's never had a rock
[Laughter]
I've got this weird outfit that I've
been meaning to get rid of why'd you
choose this saw some dead kid at the
circus
his whole family had a great aesthetic
Vibe I thought I would they're not using
it now right I've been bird watching
because my therapist thinks it's good
for me you look like a robin
well that's that's I think I think we'll
get red hood in life actually we will I
mean red Hood's a bit of an interesting
sell
um for Live Action uh because but I
think you can do they solve each other
really well you could do a solo Red Hood
movie well if Damien represents Batman
achieving what he wants as of the father
he never had and and Dick represents the
kid that left Red Hood represents the
the the failure he might perceive
himself as a trip that he could then
succeed through Damien so it could be a
lot more of a paternal story if he's the
first villain because he could literally
be accepting fatherhood as he's fighting
the kids you're theorizing right now
that red hood is the villain maybe be
the villain of the Brave in the bowl I
think it could thematically I think it'd
be an interesting way to catch up on all
the Robins if you're making a bat family
then he's the most interesting way to
make the bat family about paternal loss
yeah it's very anime too in the way
right yeah I think it could work I'd
have a setup actually that no I I really
like that pitch that's what I would
write I'd literally have a story of sons
and have a family that have different
levels of loss and then you you have the
ultimate loss come back and you're
looking at yourself as a father while
deciding as a genetic father what that
means to you but I think
don't you I guess my question would be
tonally I feel like that's semi would
like tonally and thematically that
sounds so along the lines of something
more a little more grim and serious
not not that I think Raven bull won't be
serious right but I think it will be a
little bit more fun than the Batman I
agree no and it would be very hard to be
like I lost my son like that's a very
nice but like I I don't know if you can
do a Damian Wayne story without a
commentary so it'd be interesting it's
gonna be a very hard tone it's gonna be
a really hard tone to work because you
can make it look like Batman's a
terrible dad this guy's not a hero at
all you don't make your son dude you
shouldn't have kids around you ever
that's an assassin boy
I feel like there'll be some self-aware
commentary about that yeah I think there
has to be stop adopting these kids
[Laughter]
yeah what a weird hobby uh let's keep it
going oh muffin muffin one what do you
think of Andrew Garfield's flash he
could do it but I don't want him to
plain and simple I've heard this pitch
many times Toby McGuire yeah but Toby
would be great I mean would be awesome
speed force is real uh Dan b900 was that
on that street you were doing a stream
recently where there were a lot of uh
Tom Holland yeah he's mainly Morty Morty
Mark Wahlberg
oh there's a Papa John's in this Ancient
Temple in Spain oh gee Dan v900 gun
referencing thank you Dan V
gun referencing the Morrison run when
dick is Batman but using Bruce instead
isn't good dick and Damien work far
better together with the dynamic
fair enough I'm conf uh I'm a little bit
weird
but using Bruce instead isn't as good so
oh the image they used is Dick Grayson
in the bat suit but I don't think it was
implying that dick Grayson's gonna be
the Batman uh I I see what you're saying
uh there was a time that dick took on
the mantle of Batman I don't think
that's the story they're going with I
think they're going with there's a time
when everyone takes on the men sometimes
you're eventually going to be a bad man
if you're a robin yeah like technically
that's I believe if my memory I haven't
read this book in this second that's
that's the D
in in the suit that's the D all right so
I if memory serves that's Dick Grayson
as Batman in the moment but I don't
think that's the story they're going
with that's just about an iconic image
it would be brave he said Batman though
I mean it's still he's still technically
Batman yeah but I think it's gonna be
Bruce Wayne but I just comedies yeah red
hood uh we finally got a robin and it's
the most interesting and best Robin and
Damian hot take your name's Red Hood
I have some selfish
come on now uh I think that uh Damien's
a very controversial character which is
always interesting I like Damien but I
have to live chat the knot this chat
this chat's like Damian Wayne's stupid
but like that's the fun of him yeah I
mean Damien Wayne in some ways is kind
of like uh I sort of likened Damian
Wayne to Ahsoka Tano's intro or some
people were like I don't know about this
character and then eventually like as
the character developed it became a lot
more interesting yeah but especially
with adapting Damian Wayne into even the
animated mediums is often very Hit or
Miss for people uh sometimes it could be
very annoying and not a little scrappy
not annoying and not compelling yeah
you're written well yeah yeah he because
yeah he's got he's a dark he's a dark
character ever most people seem to be me
if Batman overtakes the street overtakes
the DC Universe again
seven things yeah I just like the idea
that they were sitting them back they're
going we don't even want to start out
with Batman but we have to we gotta
mention the only thing people are going
to talk about I mean there's so many
Batman comics they're mostly great
though Oscar Franca
do you think we'll get racial ghoul or
League of associations movie in the
future with the new Batman I would love
to see it yeah I think that's what Brave
and Bold sets up they already did
grounded Razzle ghoul for The Dark
Knight trilogy now you can do Lazarus
yeah resurrecting I've been around for
thousands of years dope facial hair love
kicking it around here and I sometimes
resurrect people and they turn out
[__] insane I think we can tell you
that rash and assassins
like I think you can't introduce Damian
Wayne without them I also think they're
not going to talk A League of Shadows
we've had the League of Shadows but not
the League of Assassins and live action
yeah I I completely agree I think it's
going to be in that movie and at least
the World building of it will be
mentioned at maybe not Razz al Ghul
ghoul maybe they'll call him race no one
will notice yeah because they're
learning head Razz
Josh Dunson so is Jason Momoa safe as
Aquaman it would appear so he's safe at
DC at the very least it sounds like yeah
but we'll see maybe they'll just make
him both Aquaman and Lobo throw some
makeup on them it works talking Reckless
thank you talking Reckless with super
Chad Del Toro Swamp Thing please love
that idea what do you think of the
creature command Commandos announced a
lineup let's pull it up dude let's check
them creatures all right we gotta try to
end this in 15 minutes
Frankenstein Bride of Frankenstein uh it
looks like we've got weasel from The
Suicide Squad being our only known
member which is a fun thing to do but
this could just be a reference photo it
could but it also I saw this photo
uh when I was pulling up photos before
okay uh but before the announcement
happened got it so this isn't
necessarily like a screenshot of because
I yeah none of them are they're all
comic book reference photos I just
didn't think weasel looked so
specifically accurate that's that's very
much weasel from The Suicide Squad uh I
think that that's a fun lineup I do
think that would be that they'd use an
image of their lineup though yeah I mean
maybe
could just be a reference it could just
be a reference they could change it
honestly they could yeah so so far I
like it yeah I mean I think I think it's
a great I I like the uh I think the
lineup itself is going if it's the same
weasel carrying over yeah and I think
the suicide squad I think that'd be
excellent and he made it
um spoilers uh Del Toro Swamp Thing is a
perfect pick by the way I think that
would that would bring the exact level
of tragedy and fantasy and Horrors it's
a perfect Proclamation Javin Walkers
Peter thank you I find it interesting
that Batman the Brave and the Bold is
adapting Batman and Robin and Dick
Grayson and Damian Wayne's story why do
you think Dick's Batman was swapped out
for Bruce's because of the fact that
it's Batman and uh I think you have to
sort of sell people you have to watch
that transition happen over time before
you can sell that's why I feel like some
people are going maybe we won't start
over Clark Kent a Superman like no we're
we're definitely going to start off with
Clark Kent yeah I think it was just an
image chosen I think they're asking if
the average person will not know yeah
that that's dick like that's clearly not
Bruce Wayne you know that chin is not
this fictional chin yeah I also could be
wrong it might be uh but Bruce but I
think that is a Dick Grayson cover but
if they do start off with dick rabbit
I'd be like that is indeed
could be fun
guys Ismail Montoya thank you for being
here for contributing to the chat all
right koi what Comics do we need to
start reading crack them knocks okay so
look at the lens we got 30 seconds I'm
gonna make some comic Corner videos and
I'm gonna see how many we can crank out
but for now for here check out Supergirl
the woman of Tomorrow absolutely 100
guaranteed I would also recommend
checking out All-Star Superman Superman
um uh the the Run by Jeff Loeb and Tim
sale the Name Escapes me that is
absolutely going to be mirrored here
also uh Superman up in the sky by Tom
King I do believe it's going to be
reference then also gives you a little
bit of the flavor of that altruism and
it's removed enough I think those are
three Superman stories I think as far
for All Seasons thank you I should have
thrown it out because that was one of my
such a big to have that so good such a
solid book so super in For All Seasons
uh I would also say as far as Batman
goes the Damian Wayne stuff I personally
wouldn't start with the Brave and the
Bold uh ish stuff I would read like
Damien Wayne now because I think he's a
little more interesting I think they've
found him so maybe check out the robin
solo title that I think is still running
with Damian Wayne
80s version of Brave and Bold before it
was Batman first so you really get the
full experience the Brave and The Bull
just the title you're like ah this this
is
like a bunch of random Vigilantes just
guys just doing stuff just I'm gonna
read this book and uh I don't know
what's going on at the movie at all here
we are and they're watching The Young
and The Reckless
it's for fun uh check out planetary
probably before the authority someone uh
was very helpful in chat planetary I
think is the beginning of that whole
universe uh planetary and then the
authority are both exceptional and are
really good at showing what an else
world can be because they're basically a
commentary what's gonna be fascinating
is the authorities are commentary on
Batman and Superman the authority is an
in-universe because it's now consumed by
zdc wildstorm was doing commentary on
these characters so we're gonna have
commentary it'd be like if the boys was
in Marvel like it's a very interesting
thing so I would read those maybe first
before you establish the tone of what
you think DC is going to be because it's
going to be the most different and
disparate so check out planetary The
Authority those three Superman books and
uh Wonder uh sorry super girl woman of
tomorrow as like the first seven I'd
read those first seven I could do more
but I'm gonna say that for quite common
corner get those seven books
that was like 45 seconds I'm sorry that
was beautiful I loved it and I took
notes he's ready I love Superman For All
Seasons a book is so good sure yeah yeah
I've I'm not finished with it so it
can't be 100 like I agree with you but
yeah that's like that's Superman yeah
I've made it my goal to re I've read the
most in the DC of Batman so I'm like I
should read some more Superman's just
because he's the flagship don't worry
same with DC hey Faison Khan do you
reckon there's a there will be a
Injustice movie we got there
I think that's like a phase five like
you can't you have to love these
characters for them to feel that's an
else world yeah well it's also like if
they're corrupt and you don't love them
yet like the actors you know totally
announced worlds I think it would be a
bomb ass move if they took our main
actors and made it in elseworld's movies
that's what I'd want though that would
be cool because you need to be invested
in them yeah yeah that would be that
would be great because that's a dark ass
story that's that's like the truest
version of Superman going dark man yeah
and uh it would be it would be great
um but uh I if they especially if they
fall like the Injustice storyline like
to as close as possible which is already
very cinematic so scope like it's
gorgeous uh I think that would be neat
if they did keep the main actors from
their DC timeline I also think that you
doing these brighter stories is a way to
make that more interesting there's no
way you could just from the gate it's
got to be later yeah but it's even like
a phase five thing I'm like you can't do
that to like [__] super oh not main
Canon no no but I'm saying you be with
these characters for like three movies
and bad things yeah yeah
but it'd be a really fun else World
later yeah definitely
um Omi power thank you so much excited
for Booster Gold what do you guys think
I think we've talked about it a little
bit but I'm excited for it too and I'm
hoping they keep around uh Cobra Kai guy
uh Zolo
uh yeah let's save solo Zolo what let's
show them yeah
done didn't know it sounds great sure
there's no Jolo from from that
respectful yeah that's respectful hey
he's got a really cool name nobody
learns my last name because my first
name is cool and I feel bad I've done
that to Show Low but I only know his
first name everyone just says koi
Jamboree
[Laughter]
Jordan Garza is back RQ thank you Jordan
Arc and thank you for clarifying our cue
is real quick in gen Z my I'm gonna
assume B is best guy koi is 58 years old
I'm just trying to keep up on the
Internet what are these buttons
there are too many of them my terrific I
love Sterling uh John David Washington
Nate Parker look him up I feel you'll
agree for uh you know who might pull up
Mr terrific Kid Cudi
have you seen him act he's a good actor
he's a good actor I'm just trying to
separate my experience with his music
like that'd be interesting he's a good
actor he's a really good actor that's
fun I like that I mean maybe like I
think I think with Mr Ravinia to tap it
up and you need a nerdy side yeah that's
why someone came around because Sterling
kid Brown like puts on glasses never
dude he'd be a great Clark Kent and
people weren't racist
um
yes like he'd be incredible he's both
Superman and Clark now like it works now
sure but like nah I'm not yeah maybe
I'll take that I think he could he could
put I think we have an awesome Choice
actually that'd be really fun I like
that a lot uh Brad Cliff could
definitely do miracle and also who's
your Batman
strange Adventures one day oh all this
talk we haven't even pitched our own
Batman
um who could be Batman my God he'd have
to be I I like The Pick of Jensen Ackles
a lot I've been gravitating if you've
got a Damian Wayne that also implies
that Batman's older than Superman in
this universe I had Taran Edgerton but I
think it'd be too I think he's not quite
right no no that's too much
tall yeah sure he is
uh and and Batman if Batman's super
short next to Superman because I like
that Wolfgang guy Pedro Pascal that's
great everybody loves him uh I always
make Metro app with a younger child
my three Batman that I've always wanted
that I never got to see I think are
approaching too old my kingdom come
Batman is Jon Hamm always what happens
that's exactly what I was gonna say uh
Jon Hamm's my kingdom come especially
uh my younger two are still probably
approaching too old uh one is like a
very Debonair
um Sam whitwer I think Sam Whit would be
a great Batman he's got the chain he's
got the the the brooding and he's also
very talented he's got a cool voice and
obviously Freddie Prince Jr uh and I and
this I I cast him is also a scott-free
but I do think Jake Gyllenhall be a
great Batman I think Ralph Macho Jason
O'Meara
Caleb McLaughlin
yeah sure Kyle McLaughlin to be Batman
Caleb McLaughlin very much the age to
have a child
very very much Damian Wayne David
Harvard uh
Sadie whatever
Montgomery
Brendan Fraser you know actually Joe
Kiri great Booster Gold oh sure oh
perfect damn right perfect
I have a goal here while you run through
this yeah we are
um the they were just thank you they
were just filming Peacemaker season two
a block for me in Vancouver yeah who
said it was getting canceled it appears
to be Street shops of Smallville
spoilers oh that's cool
um do you think it'll be part of new DCU
with the Waller show yeah I think you
could probably fudge the continuity of
The Suicide Squad I mean like they have
the canonical Snyder Justice League show
up in Peacemaker but I think you could
even fudge that a little bit maybe so I
could see them
it'd be fun to tie that world in like I
I still want Rosemont his Lex back I
would like it too
um snafu I think it's gonna be tied in
for sure I think he already factored
that in snap who koi The Institute was
palpable there yes what was that
referencing uh that's when you were like
I like this
[Music]
I do like the Snyder movie and the
Snyder of the man just not Snyder the
fans well he's a Snyder of the fan I
like some of them but like that's very
insincere now we're gonna get another
Super chatter who's saying
uh
appreciate the Super Chat there buddy
thank you do you think they might adapt
the Injustice game storyline at all when
the new dcu's stable is established
appreciate such a generous super chat
but we did just answer this question
thoroughly we do think it would happen
down there ever happened short answer
being that uh it would probably be in
the else worlds but it would be great if
they still kept the main actress in the
main timeline to star in that elseworld
movie how to make that clear would be
the question
but they kind of did that with the
elseworlds animated stuff yeah Kevin
Conroy playing a bunch of different
Batman also you can start adapting those
animated movies as elseworlds like in
general it'd be exciting like once you
establish that they work you know I'm
it's it's a blunt way to approach this
but why don't you just put a title card
that says this is not a part of the main
timeline of these movies I think I think
else worlds needs to have a different
Studio bumper and also did maybe be part
of the title in some way yeah I think if
you need to say DC else worlds like that
that way people know this is separate or
you know what they could do for the DC
bumper they could just put the connected
titles on it in sequential order oh I'd
like that or something underneath vinay
Patel do you think it'd be weird that
Batman thank you for the Super Chat by
the way that Batman will be older with
his son already and Superman's starting
young as a rookie no did that would bat
Fleck but wish the two started younger
together as rookies I don't think I mean
the Superman will probably be younger
but Superman doesn't really age and the
whole and I but I don't think the
Superman's gonna start at the beginning
I think he's going to be in already I
think James gonna even said that right
yeah he's going to be already well
established already reporting and stuff
so I it's going to be start he could be
like way into it he's just younger than
the Cavalier take that's all that him
and Lois could already be together yeah
stuff you know like that we don't know
what point in the timeline it's starting
off with Superman but it's definitely
not going to be like I'm establishing
myself and I'm going to protect
Metropolis well and I think that's
something we would have to then look
forward to because we're at a point
right now where we've seen the origins
so many times that we're post that we're
trying to begin things mid-progress and
so I think with this universe if it
forges well and is well received then 10
years down the line you can do some kind
of massive overhaul reboot and start
them out as rookies again when that idea
feels fresh true yeah true so Trey Port
horror thank you Trey hey guys I'm hyped
for the Brave and the bowl as a
potential setup for the bat family who
would you guys cast as Bruce and Damon
we went through our Bruce picks let's go
through our Damien picks Finn wolfhard
Timothy Shaman
corner it really helps to advance my
comic knowledge hey thank you man we're
gonna be bringing them back uh
relatively soon and uh but yeah I think
you're talking about for Damian you said
Aiden Gallagher I think it's a great
pick I personally think that uh you know
Sadie sink Millie Bobby Brown
[Laughter]
[Music]
the kid from Haunting of Hill House with
the glasses him
can we do a comic core where we just
cast stranger things actors as DC
characters
stranger things uh cast the kid who got
his ear pulled off in mathrigan as
Damian Wayne spoilers cast Megan
um yes uh but yeah I know I think those
are great picks Heather gear thank you
again for being here you guys you know
guys are my absolute faves I want to
hear you pitch for a granny goodness
show you see in Superman Legacy granny
goodness was involved and I do think
that with this gun World granny goodness
could be because I thought granting
goodness and like it's technically part
of the Zack Snyder Justice League World
yeah there's something about him like
that's kind of a weird
it's a great goodness it's a strange
strange character and and Zach's not a
Justice literally dark and [__] which
granny goodness could work for but
there's got to be a little bit a bit
about
kookiness as as it requires yeah granny
goodness is
like an old larger lady and she's very
intensive here yeah like it's a I think
Kathy Bates I think a world of oh I
think I think you could include actress
Margo Martindale oh Margo Martindale
being incredible so the show I would do
for Grand goodness if you want my pitch
is uh you introduce the new Gods you
introduce
um scot-free Mr Miracle big Barta and
then granny goodness is trying to steal
their child for Darkseid because he's
The Prodigy uh the progeny uh apologies
of Darkseid by way of them too so granny
goodness like manipulating the literal
Gods to get her way and it's like this
Slow Burn because that way you play with
the granny element and uh the new gods
and all those things and it'd be a fun
way to tell like almost a grim fairy
tale through the gods of DC so the
weight she had a baby
so uh basically they have a child and
he's owned by dark side because he's one
because Mr Miracle being one of the new
Gods means that dark side has like kind
of uh ownership property of so he would
you know try to reclaim this child and
then granny goodness could be the one
trying to like enact it because Dark
Side wouldn't do the dirty work so
granny goodness trying to steal a child
is very like folklorian fairy tale and
that would allow you to have someone
like you know Martindale or Kathy Bates
play it the way you'd need to that's the
story that's great pick
okay learning the live stream chat
watching you guys argue this is fun
let's keep it going Trey Porter thank
you so much would gun bring in plastic
man since he was in the Brave and the
Bold cartoon show classic man is 100
coming to the DC Universe yeah and so is
Ava duvernay's New Gods I think he gets
soups to play Damian Wayne
that's the Joker he's ready oh my God
all right
[Laughter]
if this face thank you bashua uh if this
phase is successful do you think they're
going to do Flashpoint again
for being here but I don't think they'll
be doing uh I don't think they'll be
doing it again do infinite Earths or
something yeah there might be another
crisis ish like flashpoint's kind of its
own version of a crisis ish but I think
it'd be a full-on crisis I feel like if
they did another one would be like the
time machine where he just kind of just
keeps going back and trying to fix it
but it just keeps getting worse yeah
they might do a more direct literal
flash point yeah oh elongated man fragra
on the chat size I like that yeah buddy
elongated man that would be amazing and
bring back the guy who was canceled for
elongated Man in The Flash show Jordan
Garza
um hope one day we got the blue and gold
plus Miracle friend absolutely we've
talked extensively about that in the
Stream and I think it's coming I think
it's coming
uh gags where did the Blue Beetle
Aquaman movie sits to come after the
flash which resets the verse but the
Superman movie starts with the new verse
uh the Blue Beetle Aquaman movie we will
not what do you think koi I think take
it away Blue Beetle if it is uh
successful to scale will be the
beginning of uh the the Marvel Universe
in the same way that like the Hulk movie
is in the MCU but it's only like used
later so I could see Show Low getting to
play in like a year or two if the movie
does well I could also see where they
kind of like let Flashpoint wipe it away
it does sound like Aquaman I think
they're resting on the a billion the
first one made as being safe but I think
Blue Beetle is Canon as long as it does
well enough that they that they wanted
to but also the very low budget uh the
fact that the suit looks absolutely
perfect the fact that the casting is
perfect there's no reason for it not to
do well so I think they're gonna count
on it doing well and then therefore
folding it into the new DCU
[Music]
thank you for being here Douglas and
Rudd as old Ant-Man Kim and young virgin
Lang can be the model for beetle in DC
Reyes is the young version with cord
being the older with Booster Gold that's
kind of what I was saying is you could
have a different uh you know Blue Beetle
because we have Reyes as the new Blue
Beetle and he's the first Blue Beetle to
audiences that are seeing the movie but
there was a Blue Beetle that preceded
him so if you're doing something
involving time travel like Booster Gold
what if booster goes from the future to
the 80s and then you have got an 80 set
Blue Beetle Booster Gold movie which
would be so much fun because he'd be
like looking for attention on social
media it doesn't exist it's an age of
arrogance and big shoulder pads and like
you know papacity and that'd be really
fun to have Booster Gold there and maybe
learn his lessons but also allow for
another Blue Beetle that wouldn't mess
the continuity of uh sholos all right
guys I'm gonna be turning off the super
chats right now we're gonna go through
the rest of these super chats but I'm
going to turn off the
we're not going to be able to get any
more
Sidra thank you for all of you for
everyone who's been here
I just joined thank you uh for joining
this live stream and for being so
generous uh so I haven't been able to
see the new DC slate is there any news
on static shock there is not news but
there are lots of hopes and dreams for
people in the chat have been very
enthused I've been hearing for years
about a movie being made I've been a
huge fan of the cartoon
bring back static shocks some way shape
or form I think the young uh wave is
coming next and I think it'll be Teen
Titans and snack truck sweet I like it
Alex thank you for the moment
thank you what are your most anticipated
films of 2023 oh a an oddball question a
curveball personally my top three
quantumania Scream 6 and Transformers
are rise of the beasts
Scream Six shotgun Ghost Face absolutely
here for that absolutely I know some
people don't like it I'm here for it saw
10 also here for that I am really
looking forward obviously to the the
comic book movies but let's not let's go
a little bit uh experimental here uh my
number one of those comic movies across
the spider-verse but then my two are the
killer which is the new David Fincher
film out in the fall and then uh the
Covenant which is the new guy Richie
directing both Jake Gyllenhaal and uh
Anton what's his name um from Anthony
Starr Anthony Starr and Jake Dylan are
doing together for [__] guy Richie so
the Covenant the Killer and then I cross
the spider verse mine is 65.
um what's that coming out the same day
as oh Mission Impossible yeah I don't
have any interest in mission impossible
oh Oppenheimer too and Barbie
Oppenheimer Barbie
Expendables like it's trying too hard
I'm not interested John Wick four
Oppenheimer yeah the Nolan film it's
like no what
it's pretentious this man likes the
Irishman but doesn't want to see him
I was waiting for you to catch it
is this real you got this man you got
this of course I want to see you I was
so concerned for our friendship
I thought that I went earlier to a
screening of something just uh just plus
the trailer just to watch the Avatar
just so I could catch the IMAX trailer
and I was like yeah this is awesome I
finally saw a cross spider versus
trailer in theaters and it's a different
trailer but um magical let's refresh
this John
and uh I'm in I'm in the regular check
Rhodes Gallery Fan cast and go I mean
we're gonna we're gonna do a comma
corner for that you guys are pitch coil
in the chat oh yeah pitch comic Corners
pitch course comic Corner ideas I need
stuff to to stick in the knot 11
episodes the 11 announcements what I
would do yeah put them in the chat give
John a table let me think this is
we have room for one table and it is
here where the sound mixing board is in
there we should get those TV tables
those like 80s foldy ones I we have some
I have some at home those are fun here I
think uh hey you should have ID uh
Christopher Cross the fur seven
oh goodness uh thank you for for being
here and for your generous contribution
whatever currency this is what actor
from Guardians of the Galaxy do you
think will make it to the DCU and in
what character I Can See Clearly Booster
Gold I can't do that I think Palm
clementif is the first one to come in
I'm gonna make a tick tock of this not
even kidding uh I think uh Booster Gold
as Chris Pratt is genius and actually
could work uh I think Batista as uh
either etragon or
um uh would be very fun you go strange
uh
um Zoe would be a really fun either as
cheetah or
um uh there's a few like mystical
elements in zatana villains that they're
not coming to me right now Cersei I
think is one of the names uh I think
make her Talia uh who uh oh Bradley
Cooper would be an excellent Hal Jordan
um
uh who else is in that uh Vin Diesel is
the voice of Darkseid
yes yes
agreed Kevin Bacon as um Alan um uh the
first uh give away the whole okay but
make a tick tock God damn I'm just I
love casting Jordan I know you do we
gotta do a video Jordan Jesus that's a
preview
Jordan Garza Concepts or stories thank
you by the way uh from Justice League
Unlimited you want to see
um I think that's so far down the line
that like I would love to see a lot of
the uh Dynamic the Justice League
Unlimited I think did really well at
having the different Power sets play
with each other it showed like teamwork
I always think of X-Men and Justice
League Unlimited as like these Powers
work well together John and I have only
just started the just uh the the
animated DC Universe like the dcau but
one of the things I have noticed is I
enjoy the show's power dynamics a little
bit more in how they're Cooperative uh
we haven't gotten to see a lot of that
from the DC Au yet so that's an element
I'd love to see Karen Gillen is poison
ivy or genius Gordon dude she's my
Barbara Gordon but you said not to give
it away because I've got a whole pitch
here we go got a hot take honestly James
Gunn is very inconsiderate he could have
told Cavill that he wanted to reboot but
he left the Witcher and was so ready to
play Superman again and now he's lost a
rule for nothing
you know I get your frustration here but
I don't think I I don't know I mean
given the timing and the bumper cars
like I guess that has nothing to do with
Cavill coming back or like he had to he
pitched a slate which involved a young
Superman that was what DC wanted to do
and then he didn't have anything to do
with Cavill coming back and apparently
Warner Brothers was only like half there
with it so I don't think it's gun's
fault he he said he was gonna do a thing
he had to then do it and like I'm bummed
I loved cavali Superman but this is a
little short-sighted as sad as it is
it's just you you
the task that the gut the job that James
Gunn was hired to do and Peter saffron
was hired to do I just don't think you
can append
the consideration of guiding a steady
Universe for one person you know I don't
think you can do that and and so as much
as people are upset I think the
frustration directly with James Gunn I
think is a little misplaced there's so
many other yeah and that was like that
was done before we even came in so I
think there's so many conflicting
considerations that's business sadly
yeah show business I I see that we all
see the show but the business side of it
is like this is a giant Studio that was
like hemorrhaging money and I really
want it to be afloat again and I think
that it'll make all the other Studios
better because if you have competition
you work harder so WP doing well
behooves everyone to work harder and I
think James Gunn is going to be the guy
to write the ship and I and I don't love
that Cavill was a casualty of that but
unfortunately it was
red Hood's back Jason as me is great as
Robin he's the worst oh I love that
quote that that's fantastic Red Hood
also my mom's in the chats I had my mom
she's left oh mama jeandro she said
raining me in his no small feet and I
agree no small feet but we love you we
love you koi and koi's Mom Spud 1210
thank you for being here I'd love a
civil war type Green Lantern film
leading into black as night for the
Justice League level threat I think it
would be more unique and new you
um
I feel like you have like a whole secret
group of friends
like [__] around in the actual group
chat right now no I mean to get more
power to you it looks like fun uh yeah
Justice League level threat uh just
League level threat would be I mean I
think Sinestro could be if they do it
right from the beginning I think you
plant that strong yeah bring back Mark
Strong poor guy didn't ever get a chance
uh I think Sinister would be a great
opportunity I think
um I mean obviously dark side was kind
of done but I don't the Snyder cup
didn't get it theatrical so it'd be kind
of nice to see Darkseid big an ominous
uh but that seems like the easy one
um
who who else would be like unifying do
you guys have anybody because Lex Luthor
is really fun for Superman's corner but
I can't see him uniting people to that
scale Deadshot likewise uh Joker's
Batman's guy
no no he's the calendar man oh yeah he's
right there he's waiting for us no no Mr
everyone else
that's a connecting thing for all of us
yeah uh Mr mixopolitic is obviously the
thing they unite to dissolve Kevin Hart
is Robin and Dwayne Johnson is Batman
Rayne Wilson as Riddler sounds great I
want rain Wilson somewhere in this
universe I think he would be perfect for
the kind of cartoon but not quite tone
Rayne Wilson he can do he can take weird
stuff fancy monitor oh that's fun yeah
Paint Spot is a good idea dead shot I
I'm thinking they can have the Batman
Trilogy slowly gain his Bat family back
this is about him trying to reconcile
have the first one involve Nightwing
then Tim and then Red Hood it's just him
making a list and going to their homes
and they all have families
it's like he's doing AAA he goes and
apologizes for a specific interest of
things Stephanie Brown's there this is
part of my Rehabilitation
Stephanie Brown was in like one mini
series but he has to like go and check
in on her yeah yeah I think that would
be a really uh interesting family fire
night the real question is are we
getting bat cow oh granny goodness
let's be responding to the live stream
I think if anyone is a dual chat cow
it's James Gunn I think the man sure
could bring in Bat cow and elsewords are
possible bring it back how Christmas
special I want some DC Christmas
specials out of this I'm telling you
Lobo kill Santa is right there I'm
saying I would watch that so and they're
David Harper pick it would be such a fun
stunt cast I would love an else world
like the uh one thing from elseworlds
take weird little one-off ideas stories
and realize them yeah do it I'm here for
it oh my Gill thank you so much I
remember what food tastes like inside
part out loud hi all here because of koi
cast I'll look out crossover first yes
that's dick is Batman Second what do you
think Legacy implies in Superman Legacy
Connor John uh Gail great to see you
thanks for coming over from the audio uh
it implies paw Kent it does well I think
uh so I have a podcast called koi cast
and I was very excited to come talk
about this here and I pitched that on
quickcast I was plugging away we crossed
over uh Legacy I don't think ties as
directly as uh I think a sun in Conor or
John I think it's way too soon I think
that that could be a story told with
cattle I also think the show on HBO Max
having their kids uh would kind of it
doesn't quite work uh to do at the
movies as well but I do think that
Legacy will be more about
um what it means to be Superman I think
it's more about Superman's Legacy as you
look up to him I think one of the things
I have felt um now that I've seen the
and I'll totally own this I didn't watch
the Christopher Eve um Superman until
the last day of my my my birthday this
year I like literally actually here on
the channel we did it here on the
channel was the last thing I did as a 33
year old but I did immediately notice a
sense of wonder and a sense of looking
up and scope and awe even for a 45 year
old film that I don't think we've seen
to the the in in the earnest uh open
optimistic way and I think Legacy
implies like what a person has done in
the past to build a history a legacy so
to me it's more about what Superman has
accomplished and who he is in leaving a
legacy then his uh children
personally uh and that was Dick is
Batman thank you I thought so but I
wasn't sure update the chat here sure uh
Disney fan wants to know what would
happen if Greg John and Coy were the
boss of DC oh Rosenbaum definitely back
as Lex and Glenn Howerton would
definitely be Reed Richards because I'm
running both
our last one I'm ready to be green arrow
sure uh we will have to refresh once
more why don't you refresher right now
okay uh yeah if my my DCU would just
have lots of Specter Swamp Thing in
Solomon okay love uh I have I've thought
about being a casting director but uh I
was once an actor and I remember the
feeling in that room and I would want to
give everyone the part and that's top
that's not how it works I'm way too like
uh I would love to help you to do the
telling node in 99.9 of people so that
is the last one that is the last one all
right perfect thanks Paul True Believer
yo fellas we are getting a long time DC
character Sergeant Rock and the creature
commanders can't wait yeah uh Sergeant
Rock being uh probably soon to be
household name is so crazy because
that's I mean if memory serves having my
whole other show here excuse me and and
just just this yeah
so shots food for the Super Chat thank
you
but with a super chat and just bring up
the regular chat sure because this is
I've been I'm like I don't believe
people in the chat have been paying
attention to the conversation
if memory serves Sergeant Rock wasn't
the coach character um that one of my
favorite artists uh the kubert School of
Art I think Qbert did uh but but
Sergeant rock is like an OG ogdc
character so it's exciting to have the
idea of that character as something as a
household name but I don't even remember
him that well so I'm very excited
because Sergeant rock is like a very
formative uh character for comic books
themselves so very very cool
uh yeah and uh and uh yeah what what DC
are most people excited for
um
Superman Legacy okay Swamp Thing okay
it's funny
people didn't write a lot of direct
answers
to the course there's just more quandary
guys guys the question uh do you think
James won will do any here's uh
piggybacking off of uh what Thiago uh
gadino said do you think James Wan will
continue DC projects I think they you
know have a good relationship uh with
James Wan because I think you know
Aquaman being kind of uh folded in is
probably a good thing for their
relationship uh and it also means they
have a lot of faith in the movie I I
think it would have been a lot cleaner
if it wasn't good to put it before
Flashpoint and have Flashpoint end
everything so it must be good uh so I
feel like James Wan uh would want to
work with a studio that's like here's a
great time slot and a great year that
starts a thing like I feel like that's a
no-brainer also think he's a great
director so hopefully
foreign
wow the broadcast does rain yeah man
dude fire James Gunn I mean he totally
didn't uh do his job with these 11
[__] great announcements he had one
job to do today which was to put some
respect on Henry Cavill and he didn't he
just failed completely now I was really
impressed with that uh that presentation
and uh I don't know that was great he's
a poised guy he couldn't give it to
Corey be a great young Community I would
kill it and Brian Cranston is the older
one me and Brian cranston's commissioner
alrighty guys well here we are we're
gonna wrap this stream up there's a
bunch of live streams going on all at
once right now
is who's still alive I know campy is
more than likely live I'm gonna just do
a quick one round of checkups here yes
Champion definitely live with ten
thousand viewers than us let's pipe
everybody's live stream into the live
stream race Randolph let's look here uh
oh no her live ended
weak weak Grace doesn't she pick up the
steam she like hate James again she
probably just like she doesn't hate
James Oh I thought it was oh no that's
the petty because they go through the
bleeds I just so much is happening so
much Burnett's all happening right
jabby's live jabbus kablabus all right
guys I'm ready to call this are we gonna
watch us watch other reactions let's
watch ourselves would you like us to
react oh sure sure
how's heavy spoilers video doing killing
it you're gonna go trending Paul
when has Paul ever gone trending Paul
never name one time all right guys first
real gotta call it got other things
there we go now it's meta alrighty guys
well thank you so much for being here on
your way out if you could leave a like
that'd be very much appreciated thank
you to all who contributed to the super
chess and it was just for being here in
general and uh yeah this was a fun day I
had a great time I hope you guys had a
great day you all had a great time it's
been a while since we've done some
random live like this so this was fun
and I hope you all have fun can't wait
to talk some more about this it's gonna
be a year three of speculating and more
so go read some comments comic Corners
in there all right ladies and gentlemen
we'll see you soon yeah buddy thank you
for being here thank you be with you
I will have to go back